cette réunion de commission j'excuse
Catherine Deroche qui venait rejoindre
là dans les dans les minutes qui
viennent qui reprendra le relais par la
suite bien nous recevoir ce matin de ma
fatum donc directeur général de la
Caisse nationale d'assurance maladie je
vous précise que cette audition donc
fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo qui
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat Monsieur le Directeur général nous
avons souhaité vous entendre à la suite
de l'échec des négociations entre
l'assurance maladie et les reportant des
médecins libéraux afin d'établir une
nouvelle conventions médicales et
surtout la publication de la règlement
arbitral en avril nous souhaitons que
vous nous indiquiez qu'ils ont été les
principaux points d'achoppement des
négociations et comment l'acnam applique
désormais ce règlement arbitral nous
souhaitons également que vous fassiez le
point sur la perspective de reprise des
négociations vers où on va dans un
contexte semblant encore plus tendu
depuis le début de l'examen de la
proposition de loi du député Frédéric
Ventoux qui fait beaucoup causer
je vous invite à aborder ces différents
points dans un cadre dans le cadre d'un
propos liminaire et très rapidement nous
aborderons un certain nombre de
questions et je voudrais en premier lieu
la parole à Corinne Imbert qui est notre
rapporteur de la branche maladie et
Elizabeth Guenot qui vient nous
rejoindre qui est notre rapporteur
général afin de d'élargir un petit peu
le sujet et peut-être aborder un certain
nombre de points d'actualité
complémentaires je pense notamment à la
mise en place de la laque et puis
également de la lutte la lutte contre la
fraude sociale qui a été annoncée par
les ministres notamment le ministre des
comptes publics voilà Monsieur fantôme
vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup et merci de me donner
l'occasion de en effet d'intervenir sur
ces différents sujets peut-être un mot
juste avant de de d'aborder
un retour sur les négociations avec les
médecins et le règlement arbitral
partager avec la commission des affaires
sociales le dynamisme des discussions
conventionnelles qui
évidemment de se limite pas au médecin
puisque je crois que c'est important de
rappeler l'importance de ces discussions
conventionnelles qui servent à la fois à
fixer des tarifs des différents
professionnels de santé et aussi à
apporter des transformations du système
de soins et sans faire une énumération
trop longue partager avec vous que nous
avons signé le 13 avril avec des
transporteurs sanitaires un accord
pluriel 2023 2025 que nous finalisons
actuellement la négociation avec les
sages-femmes sur un nouvel avenant
accompagnant la profession soutenant
l'intervention des sages-femmes sur en
matière de santé publique et
y compris
des aidants dans l'accompagnement des
maternités nous avons ouvert
grâce aux mandats que nous a confié le
ministre quatre négociations qu'on
appelle flash un petit peu avec les
professions paramédicales
infirmiers masseur kiné
orthophoniste orthoptiste autour de la
réponse au contexte d'inflation et puis
nous espérons terminer d'ici l'été
négociation avec les dentistes de la
nouvelle convention dentaire donc pour
partager avec la commission cette
dynamisme de la vie conventionnelle je
crois que c'était important de le
rappeler vous m'interrogez sur les
raisons de de
l'échec des négociations
elles ont essentiellement à choper
autour de la problématique du 30 euros
de l'art valorisation de la consultation
de médecine générale à 30 euros puisque
nous avions proposé
cette bascule entre guillemets à 30
euros mais dans un cadre celui d'un
engagement territorial qui m'était en
face ces revalorisations très
significatives près de 20%
d'augmentation des honoraires des
médecins généralistes avec
un certain nombre de réponses à apporter
dans les besoins des territoires qui
s'agissent de la prise en charge des
patients de la réponse à la permanence
des soins aux soins non programmés
l'exercice coordonné donc sans revenir
dans le détail c'est essentiellement
autour de cette problématique que la
négociation n'a pas abouti puisque nous
avions proposé une revalorisation socle
à 26,50 € et également donc ce 30 euros
dans le cadre de l'engagement
territorial beaucoup d'autres
items étaient proposés mesure de lutte
contre les déserts médicaux soutien à
l'exercice on est en zone soudain
simplification de la rémunération sur
objectif de santé publique
évolution de l'octane du dispositif qui
permet d'encadrement de dépassement
d'honoraires voilà c'est ces
dispositions
[Musique]
avec les partenaires conventionnels ce
qui a abouti en effet à la saisine de
d'un arbitre ou d'une arbitre en
l'espèce puisqu'il s'agissait d'Annick
Morel qui a donc à rédiger ce règlement
arbitral après audition des différentes
parties prenantes et qui
a donc édicté un règlement qui vaut
convention médicale pour 5 ans
obligation est en fait aux parties
conventionnelles de se remettre autour
de la table dans un délai de deux ans
après la publication du règlement
arbitral
ce règlement porte essentiellement l'art
valorisation à 26,50 € au premier
novembre
l'assouplissement des conditions de
recours aux assistants médicaux que nous
avions proposé dans le cadre de la de la
négociation et également
la mise en place d'une consultation à 60
euros pour les médecins traitants qui
prennent un patient en affection de
longue durée en maladie chronique qui
n'a pas de médecin traitant j'y
reviendrai ça fait partie évidemment de
nos
priorités le règlement arbitral
pérennise également les mesures autour
des soins non programmés avec la
majoration des consultations
réguliers de 15 euros et le tarif de 100
euros de l'heure pour le l'activité de
régulation
donc ce règlement arbitral se met en
oeuvre de notre côté
nous avons engagé l'accompagnement des
des médecins libéraux autour des deux
thématiques principales qui sont le plan
d'action autour des personnes en
affection de longue durée qui n'ont pas
de médecin traitant vous savez que c'est
un objectif fixé par le président de la
République est repris par le ministre de
la Santé qui a confié à l'assurance
maladie le déploiement opérationnel de
ce de ce plan d'action qui nous amène à
nous mobiliser avec les CPTs les les
élus locaux les associations de patients
et les maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires autour de solutions
pour permettre de trouver un médecin
traitant pour ses patients qui n'en
n'ont pas qui sont en affection de
longue durée à peu près 700 000 un peu
plus de 700 000 patients à la fin de
l'année 2022
et donc ce plan se déploie depuis
maintenant quelques semaines nous avons
écrit à l'ensemble des assurés
concernés pour les avertir que nous
allions nous mobiliser leur permettre
d'exercer leurs droits d'opposition nous
sommes en train d'écrire à l'ensemble
des médecins libéraux qui voient
régulièrement
ses patients alors même qu'ils ne sont
pas médecin traitant on sait que dans
les 700 000 patients qui n'ont pas de
médecin traitants qui sont dans la
réalité une diversité très importante
20% 20% d'entre eux n'ont pas vu un
médecin
du tout de l'année un quart d'entre eux
voient régulièrement le même médecin et
donc nous avons voilà engagé cette
opération et au-delà de ça au niveau
local beaucoup de mobilisation sont en
train de se déployer au niveau des CPTs
pour notamment
identifier les médecins libéraux qui
seraient volontaires pour prendre
davantage de patients en ALD qui n'ont
pas de médecin traitant et donc partager
un effort qui évidemment s'il repose que
sur quelques-uns sera difficile mais
50000 médecins généralistes pour 700 000
patients en est si on arrive à générer
cette mobilisation collective alors nous
pensons qu'il est possible
d'infléchir la courbe qui si on ne fait
rien les 700 000 de fin d'année 2022 ce
seront plutôt 800 000 patients en ALD
qui n'auront pas de médecin traitant
d'ici la fin de l'année donc notre
objectif est vraiment d'inverser la
courbe ça c'est le premier sujet de
mobilisation le deuxième sujet c'est au
tour des assistants médicaux
comme je le disais reprenant les
propositions que nous avions formulées
dans la négociation et qui était
d'ailleurs largement consensuel avec les
syndicats de médecins nous donc nous
allons
engager une campagne de communication et
d'information importante sur les
nouvelles règles puisque dorénavant il
n'y a plus de lien avec la zone
d'exercice il n'y a plus le lien avec un
exercice coordonné chaque médecin
libéral peut bénéficier d'un assistant
médical y compris à temps plein avec une
aide de l'Assurance Maladie une aide
dont je rappelle qu'elle est pérenne dès
lors que les objectifs de patientèle qui
sont fixés dans le cadre du contrat
entre l'assurance maladie et le médecin
sont tenus donc ça n'est pas qu'une aide
à l'embauche c'est une aide à l'emploi
et c'est une aide significative puisque
pour un équivalent temps plein c'est une
aide annuelle de 21000 euros 21000 euros
par an pour accompagner le l'embauche le
recrutement d'un assistant médical et le
recul que nous avons nous montre que ça
fonctionne puisque trois ans un peu plus
maintenant 4 ans après le lancement 2019
de ce dispositif nous voyons que les
médecins qui ont recruté un assistant
médical en moyenne augmente leur fil
active autour de 10% et donc sans
travailler plus je le redis sans
travailler plus et les conditions de
travail qui sont modifiées qui sont
changées qui sont améliorées et donc le
dispositif
fonctionne
sur
sur le
sur maintenant vous m'interrogez sur les
donc voilà en tout cas de notre point de
vue ces deux ces deux éléments
consultation plan d'action à LD 100
médecins traitant et assistant médicaux
sont deux éléments très importants qui
même si on est sous le l'égide d'un
règlement arbitral qui volontairement
n'a pas porté transformation
structurelle l'arbitre a considéré et je
crois que c'était la vocation de
arbitral d'être plutôt dans une logique
de continuité pour repasser la main aux
partenaires conventionnelles à un moment
néanmoins en 2023 nous sommes mobilisés
pour déployer une feuille de route
ambitieuse sur l'accès aux soins tel
qu'elle a été définie par le ministre de
la Santé de la prévention autour de ces
thématique là du gain de temps médical
de l'accompagnement des médecins et de
ce point de vue là aussi je me permets
même si c'est pas strictement un sujet
conventionnel de citer aussi le
déploiement du plan d'action autour des
simplifications administratives puisque
nous avons missionné les partenaires
conventionnels et missionné le docteur
Franzoni et Pierre Albertini ancien
directeur de la caisse de Paris pour
faire des propositions à l'assurance
maladie et au ministre en matière de
simplification de la vie administrative
des médecins qui a donné un plan
présenté par le ministre en au mois de
février dernier et que nous déployons
autour notamment de l'allègement des
pièces justificatives demandées au
médecin de l'amélioration de la qualité
des réponses apportées par l'assurance
maladie le ministère de la Santé de
travail également sur la diminution des
certificats
inutiles qui prennent effectivement du
temps
inutile au médecin et donc ça fait
partie aussi des demandes fortes qui
sont opposées par les médecins mais je
pense que vous voulez
vous avez l'occasion de les écouter sur
les territoires
s'agissant de la reprise des discussions
nous l'avons de les redit à plusieurs
reprises nous sommes très attachés au
dialogues conventionnel avec les
différentes professions de santé et avec
les médecins libéraux nous souhaitons
réengager ces discussions parce que je
crois qu'elles sont quelque part les
seuls à même de
d'accompagner les transformations du
système de santé de répondre aux enjeux
à la fois d'attractivité de la médecine
libérale et de réponse aux besoins de
soins de la population nous sommes en
train de travailler aux conditions de la
reprise de ces discussions en termes de
méthodes de calendrier de grands
objectifs j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
si chacune des parties prenantes
assurance maladie comme médecin repart
avec les mêmes positions et les mêmes
propositions on risque d'aboutir au même
résultat donc il nous faut bien
réfléchir aux conditions qui permettront
d'y retourner entre guillemets dans des
dans des bonnes conditions tout en
partageant mais vous l'avez évoqué sur
le sénateur le calendrier relativement
chargé actuellement finalement donc il
est aussi nécessaire que les discussions
puissent reprendre dans un climat de
sérénité et donc nous y travaillons en
souhaitant effectivement que cette
reprise puisse se faire et qu'elle
puisse être
fructueuse voilà ce que je pouvais dire
sur ce sujet là je ne sais pas si vous
souhaitez que j'aille au-delà sur les
autres thématiques où on s'arrête là à
ce stade oui oui on va arrêter on va
continuer le débat à travers les
questions qui vont vous être posées
voilà je vais te donner le porno à
Corinne cohenber
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur merci pour pour ces propos
introductifs
tout le monde est en mémoire évidemment
que les négociations conventionnelles
sont passées aussi dans un climat
au-delà des attentes des professionnels
un petit peu tendu crispé par notamment
une proposition de loi qui était sur
l'accès au soins et que ça certainement
pas à l'époque arranger l'ambiance des
négociations autour de la table
ce projet de convention médicale qui est
proposé par latin donc a été refusé par
les syndicats motifs qui ne permettaient
pas le choc d'attractivité attendue et
conditionné à la plupart des
augmentations tarifaires à des
obligations supplémentaires en matière
d'accès aux soins quelles enseignements
tirez-vous de cette échec et la CNAM
abandonne-t-elle l'idée d'augmentation
tarifaire conditionnée de revenir un
petit peu sur le cœur du sujet j'allais
dire du début de l'année
et éventuellement quelles autres outils
conventionnels envisagez-vous pour
améliorer l'offre de soins sur le
territoire vous aviez évoqué les
patients à LD vous avez évoqué
l'assistant médical qu'effectivement
vont plutôt vu de ma place dans le bon
sens mais est-ce que vous avez d'autres
outils dans votre voilà dans votre
besace et est-ce que vous pourriez nous
en parler sur le règlement arbitral
bien les les professionnels le juge
insuffisants voire terriblement
insuffisant il souhaite une réouverture
urgente des négociations avant l'été le
ministre s'est prononcé peut-être pour
une réouverture des négociations après
l'été vous venez de dire que l'alcalier
était assez chargé est-ce que vous êtes
en ligne avec le ministre en clair pour
plutôt envisager une réouverture des
négociations conventionnelles à la
rentrée après l'été pour que les choses
se passent de façon le plus sereinement
possible donc est-ce que vous pouvez
nous indiquer clairement quand est-ce
que les négociations de votre point de
vue pourraient pourrait reprendre
quelles doivent être selon vous les
[Musique]
dont l'exécution monte une nouvelle fois
un dépassement par rapport à la dernière
prévision actualisée en loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale 2023
pour 2022 un dépassement qui cette année
est encore substantiel par rapport à la
prévision initiale puisque c'est plus de
10,4 milliards d'euros et celui-ci n'est
plus seulement le fait de la crise
sanitaire vous en vous en conviendrez ça
dépense de l'ordre de près de 250
milliards d'euros n'apparaît absolument
pas pilotable n'apparaît absolument plus
pilotable pour 2023 le comité d'alerte
dans son avis du 7 juin appel à une
grande vigilance sans tirer encore la
sonnette d'alarme comment dissipez-vous
la trajectoire 2023 et vous
préparez-vous à des mesures d'économie
pour tenir la trajectoire initiale je
vous remercie
monsieur le directeur nous laisser
répondre
merci
je le disais le repartir sur une
négociation qui n'a pas fonctionné
implique
d'y venir avec des propositions
nouvelles à différentes
de part et d'autre d'ailleurs mais je ne
peux m'exprimer que pour que pour
l'assurance maladie
il est
sans doute
juste de considérer que
l'un des éléments qui a été mal compris
par nos parties prenantes a été le lien
entre la revalorisation de l'acte
je parle bien de relations de l'acte et
un certain nombre de contreparties
une relation individuelle de ce point de
vue là ça nous fait réfléchir sur la
façon de Ré aborder le sujet tout en
partageant avec vous que les problèmes
n'ont pas disparu et que
les difficultés je l'évoquais des 700
000 patients en ALD à trouver un médecin
traitant son réel vous connaissez on
connaît les perspectives démographiques
qui se résument par un effet de ciseaux
bien connu des économistes entre en
l'espèce plus de patients et moins de
médecins quand bien même je partage avec
vous que l'année 2021 de 1500 médecins
généralistes se sont installés sur le
territoire ce qui est deux fois plus que
au début des années 2010 deux fois plus
donc
mesurons bien aussi que la dynamique
démographique elle commence à
s'enclencher même si à l'inverse pas le
flux de départ à la retraite qui est
elle aussi s'accélère mais donc nous
savons que nous allons le ministre l'a
dit à plusieurs reprises connaître ces
prochaines années des tensions
importantes donc comment nous y
répondons et comment nous accompagnons
la profession médicale sur des
transformations qui permettent de
répondre à ce défi d'une demande d'accès
aux soins plus importante et donc voilà
donc
autant nous avons porté cette logique
d'engagement territorial autant nous
réfléchons nous réfléchissons à essayer
de trouver les moyens
d'incitation différentes
vous l'avez évoqué notamment nous
évidemment aujourd'hui les médecins
libéraux sont rémunérés principalement à
l'acte mais la part forfaitaire à
notoirement augmenté depuis une
quinzaine d'années notamment le forfait
médecin traitant est un outil qui est
pour le coup bien appréhendé par les
médecins et qui reconnaît aussi ce rôle
de très important de prise en charge des
patients via cette rémunération
forfaitaire est-ce qu'il faut davantage
utiliser ce levier ça fait partie des
réflexions que nous que nous avons
et donc voilà de toute façon encore une
fois il faudra de nouvelles propositions
mais il faudra aussi des solutions qui
répondent aux besoins de de santé de des
assurés sociaux et en redisant aussi
notre
comment dirais-je conviction que le
maintien de l'attractivité de la
médecine libérale est un enjeu très
important je le reportage à nouveau
chaque jour les généralistes libéraux de
ce pays voient un million de patients
les spécialistes à peu près le même
niveau on parle souvent des 20 millions
de passages aux urgences par an il y a
un million de patients qui sont vus dans
les cabinets des médecins généralistes
libéraux donc c'est absolument majeur
pour l'assurance maladie en effet de
trouver les moyens de maintenir cette
attractivité
voire de l'améliorer et en même temps de
mettre ses professionnels en situation
de répondre à une demande de soins qui
augmente de ce point de vue là je le
redis aussi les outils que nous
déployons aujourd'hui l'assistant
médical si massivement nous arrivons à
faire qu'il y a 10000 contrats
d'assistant médicaux qui sont signés à
l'horizon fin 24 début 25 on aura fait
aussi des progrès substantiels parce que
ça veut dire du temps médical
supplémentaire disponible pour les
patients donc pas forcément nécessaire
de réinventer des choses très
compliquées parce que
ces mécanismes là produisent des
résultats
sur le sur le calendrier
voilà je l'ai dit dès lors que nous
pourrons
identifier les conditions permettant de
reprendre la négociations dans les
reprendrons et les textes sont assez
clairs puisqu'ils prévoient bien que
toutes négociation toute reprise de
négociation passe par
l'envoi de ligne directrice de la part
du ministre de la santé et de la
prévention donc par définition il ne
peut pas y avoir de calendrier des
synchronisé et de ce point de vue là
évidemment
on partage la nécessité de réenclencher
les choses je le je le redis le
règlement arbitral ça a été le cas des
deux précédents du côté qui ont déjà eu
lieu du côté des médecins et des
dentistes ce sont généralement des
outils qui voilà permettent d'assurer
une forme de continuité et de repasser
la balle aux partenaire conventionnel
partageons néanmoins que cet outil dit
de continuité il se traduit tout de même
par un investissement de l'Assurance
Maladie de 700 millions d'euros
700 millions d'euros plus 100 millions
d'euros des organismes complémentaires
nous avons bien perçu que les 26,50 €
pouvaient être mal reçus par les
médecins ça représente néanmoins une
augmentation de la lettre clé de 6%.
l'augmentation de 6%
et ce qui doit être prise en compte mais
voilà nous souhaitons effectivement
réenclencher les discussions avec nos
partenaires je crois qu'ils le
souhaitent aussi il faut qu'il trouve
les voilà le la bonne méthode nous
voulons aussi vous l'avez dit la
discussion précédente c'est fait dans un
climat difficile très difficile nous
avons dû faire face à
campagne très violente sur les réseaux
sociaux malheureusement l'information
extrêmement déformée sur les
propositions de l'assurance maladie à
aucun moment nous avons pensé à obliger
l'ensemble des médecins libéraux à
travailler tous les samedis matin à
aucun moment nous avons pensé obligé les
médecins libéraux à travailler plus ça
n'était pas le sens de l'engagement
territorial que nous avons proposé donc
à nous également de
travailler aussi à une méthode qui nous
permette peut-être de mieux nous faire
comprendre de mieux intégrer la réalité
aujourd'hui des réseaux sociaux qui sont
un élément de la négociation
conventionnelle je le vois sur d'autres
négociations qui pèsent en réalité ça
n'est pas anecdotique qui pèse y compris
sur nos partenaires conventionnels parce
qu'ils sont sous pression de cette de ce
mode d'expression et donc voilà des
éléments de
méthode que nous partageons
sur
sur l'ONDAM vous m'interrogez sur le
long dame
je me permets de partager avec vous mais
je sais que vous le mesurez très bien
également
l'ampleur des chocs
22 et encore 22 22 n'oublions pas que 22
c'est le premier semestre 22 c'est la
vague au micro c'est des niveaux d'arrêt
de travail jamais vu c'est des niveaux
de test jamais vu c'est la c'est la fin
entre guillemets enfin en tout cas c'est
une campagne de vaccination un peu moins
intense en 2020 mais tout de même encore
importante et donc des chocs exogènes et
absolument imprévisible qui explique
tout de même très largement la dynamique
de la dépense
donc nous sommes en train évidemment
dans d'en sortir c'est la raison pour
laquelle je considère pour ma part que
l'on dame reste
un outil pilotable d'ailleurs il doit le
rester il doit le rester puisque si nous
ne fixons pas sous l'égide du Parlement
des règles et des objectifs sur des
dépenses qui en effet aujourd'hui
dépassent de 150 milliards d'euros enfin
à peu près je pense que ça sera
extrêmement problématique à la fois en
termes
financier et si je peux me permettre
politique vu l'ampleur des sujets que
porte cet objectif de de dépense donc il
doit la rester pilotable de ce point de
vue là d'ailleurs on peut saluer le fait
que les mécanismes de supervision
fonctionnent le comité d'alerti réuni la
auditionné les parties prenantes dont la
Caisse nationale d'assurance maladie il
a appelé à une grande vigilance mais il
n'a pas il n'a pas déclenché le
mécanisme d'alerte
donc de ce point de vue là nous
participons et de cette grande vigilance
je partage avec vous que techniquement
il nous est encore assez difficile de
bien mesurer
l'explication des dynamiques de dépenses
parce que quand nous comparons le
premier semestre ayant été le premier
trimestre puisque sans rentrer dans la
technique en date de soins nous
disposons que des chiffres du premier
trimestre le premier trimestre 2023 est
difficile à lire parce que le premier
trimestre 2022 a été extrêmement chahuté
en termes de voilà de de comportement
des acteurs de soins donc est-ce qu'on a
une dynamique qui est qui s'explique
parce que le premier trimestre 2022 a
été très particulier très atome sur
certains chants ou est-ce que ça masque
une dynamique plus importante c'est ce
que nous sommes en train de travailler
nous allons regarder le deuxième
trimestre mais donc aujourd'hui compte
tenu du fait que le mécanisme d'alerte
n'a pas été déclenché
un plan d'économie n'est pas à l'ordre
du jour puisque c'est dès lors que
l'alerte est déclenché que le mécanisme
se mette en place mais évidemment nous
sommes avec nos collègues du ministère
très attentifs à
aux différents éléments qui peuvent
impacter les les longues dames 2023 y
compris pour ce qui est de ma
responsabilité à la fois les programmes
de maîtrise médicalisée et les
négociations conventionnelles même si du
fait de la du fait de la règle qui fait
que les négociations conventionnelles
prennent effet avec 6 mois de d'écart
par rapport à la date de signature
aujourd'hui les négociations que
nous-monnaies n'auront pas d'impact sur
2023 donc aujourd'hui il y a pas de il y
a pas de de surprise entre guillemets à
attendre sur la dame 2023 mais c'est
vrai que nous sommes vigilants sur la
l'évolution des dépenses de cette année
très bien c'est la parole elle les avait
donné
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le Directeur Général pour ses
propos déjà luminaires et ensuite ces
explications qui ont été données à ma
collègue Corinne Imbert je voudrais à
travers vous remercier l'ensemble des
agents des caisses départementales
d'assurance maladie qui
sont effectivement sur le terrain mais
sont plus que ça ils sont les
partenaires de beaucoup d'institutions
sur les départements mais aussi les
interlocuteurs privilégiés de l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens et ils répondent avec
efficacité en tout cas moi j'ai eu
l'occasion de voir que les choses se
font de façon exemplaire donc merci à
vous et à vos agents nous avons déjà
abordé un certain nombre de sujets je
voulais quelques précisions avant
d'aborder des questions qui sont propres
à leur apporteur du budget de la
Sécurité sociale sur
les outils qui sont aujourd'hui à notre
disposition pour rendre l'accès aux
soins plus comment plus plus facile on a
les infirmières en pratique avancée
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
quelques éléments sur
de comment de différence entre les
véritables 100 médecins traitant et ceux
qui en ont donc c'était des petites
informations et sur je voudrais un autre
chiffre aussi sur les
déconventionnements parce que on dit
aujourd'hui qu'il y a beaucoup de
médecins qui qui ne veulent plus être
conventionnés pour X raisons mais moi je
crois qu'il y a une effectivement
peut-être une tendance mais je voudrais
avoir la confirmation par les chiffres
moi j'ai peur que toutes les
propositions qui sont faites
actuellement sur
l'obligation d'installation en tout cas
l'incitation à s'installer dans des dans
des désirs médicaux encore faudrait-il
les déterminer tout ça
il y a comme une réaction de la part
aussi des médecins et on peut comprendre
de se dire bon bah voilà ça suffit moi
je fais mon petit travail tout seul et
de toute façon j'aurai toujours du monde
puisque il y a besoin il y a besoin de
consultation de temps médical donc je
voudrais avoir cette
ce nom alors abordons maintenant les
questions qui qui sont propres au budget
vous avez comme moi remarqué que la Cour
des comptes a consacré tout un chapitre
sur la fraude comment dans son dernier
rapport la fraude de prestation sociale
elle y présente les évaluations de la
fraude réalisée par la CNAM dans 6
domaines correspondant au total à une
fourchette entre 1,1 milliard et 1,3
milliards d'euros alors on a vu qu'on
peut extrapoler en fait c'est ces
éléments là sur la base d'une règle de
trois en fait tout simplement et
elle évalue la fraude total pour la CNAM
un montant compris entre 3,8 milliards
d'euros et 4,5 milliards d'euros alors
est-ce que vous cette estimation elle
vous semble cohérente c'est la première
question
et puis la courte des comptes indique la
CNAM a pour objectif
d'estimer en 2024 l'ensemble des fraudes
de prestations versées par les caisses
d'assurance maladie
parce que d'abord cet objectif aussi
vous semble tenu en tout cas pouvoir
être retenu par vous qu'est-ce que la
CNAM prévoit de faire concrètement et
selon quelle échéancier pour améliorer
sa connaissance de la fraude parce que
c'est ça en fait on a eu quelques
articles de presse dernièrement qui
voilà qui apporte des précisions mais en
même temps qui donne des chiffres un peu
différents donc soyons clairs là dessus
ma deuxième question c'est sur le sujet
plus général du paiement à bon droit
paiement à bon endroit je veux rappeler
que c'est le paiement par la branche
maladie de ce qu'elle doit aux assurer
la Cour des comptes indique dans son
rapport sur la certification des comptes
de la Sécurité sociale pour 2022 que
dans le seul cas du remboursement des
frais de santé les erreurs qui sont
généralement du à l'assurer en fait
qui sont généralement en faveur de
l'assuré sont passés de 1,9 milliards
d'euros en 2020 à 2,5 milliards d'euros
en 2021 et 3,4 milliards d'euros en 2022
qu'est-ce que vous entendez prévoir pour
faire inverser cette tendance
le directeur je crois que je n'ai fini
merci monsieur
merci beaucoup
merci d'abord pour les propos
introductifs que je transmettrai bien
sûr au réseau et qui ont à coeur en
effet d'être des acteurs des sur les
territoires et les partenaires pour
l'ensemble des acteurs
sur les chiffres sur le sur les sur les
patients traitant ça me permet de en
effet de peut-être de clarifier quelque
chose
clairement dans les 720
000 patients en ALD qui à la fin de
l'année 2022 n'avait pas le médecin
traitant il y a des situations
extrêmement différentes
extrêmement différentes je l'ai évoqué
il y a il y en a un sur cinq qui n'ont
vu aucun médecin dans l'année
voilà il y en a aussi à peu près un
quart qui voient régulièrement le même
médecin donc clairement il y a une
distinction mais ça peut-être que on l'a
suffisamment dit mais nous l'avons
partagé avec l'ensemble des membres du
comité de pilotage
présidé par le ministre de la Santé
lorsque le plan a été lancé il y a
clairement des gens qui ne sont pas
administrativement
enregistrés dans les bases de
l'assurance maladie comme ayant déclaré
un médecin traitant mais qui voit
régulièrement le même médecin et c'est
la raison pour laquelle dans les actions
et ça pour le coup on a été très
transparent dans les actions qui sont en
train d'être déployées là au moment où
je vous parle les courriers sont en
train d'être adressés nous envoyons des
courriers
assez médecin là qui voient
régulièrement le même patient en leur
disant docteur dans nos bases vous voyez
régulièrement et en lui donnant la liste
nominative c'est la raison pour laquelle
on a écrit avant aux assurés pour leur
demander d'accord pour utiliser ces
données on va dire voilà d'après les
éléments à notre position vous voyez
régulièrement monsieur Dupont Madame
Dupont est-ce que vous seriez d'accord
pour les prendre comme médecin traitant
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a un
certain nombre aussi de médecins qui
disent je le Serge je le vois mais en
fait je suis pas vraiment je ne sais pas
si je souhaite être leur médecin
traitant parce que c'est une
responsabilité supplémentaire donc il
faut que ça reste un choix du médecin de
dire ok on a la faiblesse de penser où
on espère évidemment qu'un certain
nombre d'entre eux qui en ont vraiment
important d'entre eux vont dire oui et
vont dire j'accepte de prendre cette
charge-là et de ce point de vue là dès
lors qu'ils vont nous renvoyer la liste
en disant oui entre guillemets je suis
d'accord on fera cette forme
d'appariement et donc voilà de ce point
de vue là on a ben je pense qu'il faut
bien distinguer les choses il y a une
très grande diversité de situations et
quand on regarde la consommation de
soins 700 000 il y a vraiment des gens
qui n'ont aucune consommation de soi
j'aurais presque envie de vous dire que
peut-être qu'il y a aussi des patients
en ALD qui des années sont en meilleure
situation parce que leur affection
chronique est moins grave que à d'autres
moments donc il faut vraiment
différencier la consommation de soins
qui est hétérogène maintenant je pense
qu'il y a un assez fort consensus pour
se dire que
considérait qu'aujourd'hui on a 700000
personnes qui n'ont qui n'ont pas mal
déclaré ou un nombre important d'entre
eux n'ont pas véritablement de médecin
traitant de médecins qui voient
régulièrement c'est un problème de santé
publique et donc nous allons continuer à
nous mobiliser mais je crois que le
ministre présidera début juillet un
nouveau comité de pilotage et on fera le
point et on redonnera tous ces éléments
chiffrés mais là dessus voilà il y a
bien
cette distinction là vous m'interrogez
sur
les chiffres de décomventionnement ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que depuis
le début de l'année enfin depuis la fin
des négociations nous avons enregistré
demande de déconventionnement pour les
médecins généralistes et trois demandes
pour les médecins spécialistes voilà ce
sont les chiffres donc
je ne commande pas mais ce sont les
chiffres mais nous restons extrêmement
attentifs à ce sujet extrêmement
j'ai demandé aussi au directrice au
directeur de caisse dès lors qu'ils
avaient une demande de rentrer en
discussion avec le médecin de
s'expliquer de partager c'est une
décision lourde c'est d'abord une
décision lourde pour les patients
puisque ça leur prive ça les prix
potentiellement de remboursement et donc
c'est une décision qui ne doit pas être
pris à la légère et à nouveau je
regrette très vivement les appels aux
décorations qui ont pu être
lancé par certains responsables
s'agissant des sujets
liés à la fraude et si vous me le
permettez je laisserai marche-leur
directeur délégué aux finances de
l'Assurance Maladie apportée un certain
nombre d'éléments complémentaires
simplement
souligner d'abord que nous continuons le
travail d'évaluation brique par brique
je le redis il n'y a pas une fraude à
l'assurance maladie il y a des fraudes à
l'assurance maladie les fraudes
travaillent les fraudes à la C2S les
fraudes à la T2A les fraudes des
infirmiers libéraux les fraudes à
l'identité ce sont des ensembles en
réalité très très différents et donc
nous ne cherchons pas de notre côté un
chiffre nous cherchons une évaluation et
nous cherchons pas d'ailleurs nous
menons une évaluation la plus
scientifique possible je crois
d'ailleurs que la Cour a souligné les
travaux engagés et donc nous continuons
Marc qui reviendra brique par brique on
a fait un certain nombre d'oppression de
santé on n'a pas fini on va continuer
parce que c'est long c'est des méthodes
statistiques assez lourdes pour essayer
ben voilà de dire l'A de tel ou tel
profession de telle de tel type de
recours à la C2S ou aux arrêts de
travail des assurés voilà quel
évaluation on peut porter mais quoi
qu'il en soit
en terme macro il est certain que
les évaluations que nous menons
justifient une mobilisation renforcée
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
en lien évidemment direct avec le
ministre des comptes publics fixé un
objectif ambitieux de 500 millions
d'euros de rendement des opérations de
lutte contre l'afro de en 2024 en
portant que notre chiffre
avant 2022 notre le plus haut chiffre
était de 290 millions d'euros donc ça
veut dire une très nette accélération
des des opérations et de leur rendement
que nous avons atteint à nouveau record
si j'ose dire je n'aime pas le terme
mais montant maximum à 315 millions
d'euros en 2022 dans le bilan que nous
avons partagé il y a quelques quelques
semaines en partageant le fait que c'est
un montant qui n'intègre pas la
tarification l'activité puisque les
contrôles sur la T2A ont des suspendus
du fait de la de la crise et de la
garantie de financement et donc nous
allons poursuivre ces travaux
d'évaluation mais je pense que Marc il
reviendra et s'agit sans de juillet des
erreurs mais là aussi je laisserai
marche-leur détailler les choses il faut
bien l'intégrer aussi les spécificités
des années 2021 et des années 2022 vous
évoquiez en évoquait l'augmentation des
dépenses et de type de dépenses il y a
un certain nombre d'éléments objectifs
qu'ils expliquent ces éléments là en
partageant avec vous néanmoins que sans
en faire exagérément à satisfait site
mais que nous avons à nouveau été
certifié les contes de l'assurance
maladie ont un nouveau été certifié en
2022 alors même que nous avons dû faire
face à une typologie de dépenses et une
typologie d'opération tout à fait
dérogatoire dans un certain nombre de
cas et je crois ce qui témoigne là aussi
de l'investissement des équipes pour
piloter et gérer les comptes d'une
manière rigoureuse mais je laisse
peut-être en marque
merci beaucoup
oui alors effectivement peut-être dans
les chiffres en complément de ceux que
vous avez cité vous indiquer qu'on a
produit une évaluation pour 6 catégories
de enfin de droit ou de professionnels
de santé puisque en fait on alterne les
évaluations en touchant à la fois des
sujets qui concernent plus les assurés
ou les professionnels de santé ce qui
est tout à fait tout à fait logique on
n'a pas nécessairement vocation à en
faire la somme puisque l'enjeu et ce qui
est assez fondamental c'est que on a une
stratégie à la fois pour les dispositifs
de contrôle au sens large également pour
les dispositifs de lutte contre la
fraude qui est organisé autour de 4 axes
4 piliers le premier étant l'évaluation
concrètement l'évaluation elle nous
permet de savoir où il faut qu'on cible
nos actions là où on a les principaux
préjudices financiers donc c'est pour ça
que l'évaluation est assez fondamentale
elle nous permet de mieux connaître
les erreurs de facturation ou les
atypiques
abus et fraude donc qui dévoilent qui
dévoile le système
et donc en fait pour chaque catégorie de
d'évaluation qu'on a qu'on a produit on
a une fourchette
haute et une fourchette basse peut-être
en chiffres le directeur général évoqué
les résultats de l'exercice 2022 se dire
qu'on évolue quand même dans un
environnement où les chiffres sont
extrêmement conséquents puisque pour les
deux branches maladie ATMP on a liquidé
à peu près 257 milliards d'euros de
prestation 2022
ça représente à peu près 1,6 milliards
de factures unitaires reçus dans le
système d'information donc c'est des
flux extrêmement conséquents et il y a
une grande partie des contrôles qui sont
réalisés par le système d'information le
système d'information rejette quasiment
30 millions de factures et là bon plutôt
sur des sujets qui sont des sujets de
conformité
je peux pas dire assez basique mais des
sujets de droits et des sujets de
cohérence entre entre nos bases et s'il
ajoute ensuite 16 millions de contrôles
là qui sont des contrôles à vocation
nettement plus ciblées donc cumulé tout
ça nous a permis d'atteindre un
montant total de préjudice stoppé et
détecter en 2022 667 millions d'euros
donc ce qui est dans le cadre des
échanges qu'on mène avec la Cour des
comptes et évidemment important
puisqu'on a une trajectoire dans le
cadre de la certification et puis par
ailleurs la Cour dans son dans le Ralph
faisait justement le suivi des
évolutions mises en oeuvre sur la fraude
donc voilà cette première brique
évaluation est fondamentale et elle
s'accompagne de trois autres briques la
seconde la deuxième
c'est tout ce qui est dispositif de
prévention intégrée dans nos systèmes
d'information ou d'accompagnement des
procès de santé à l'installation puisque
ce qui est fondamental dans la relation
qu'on a avec les procès de santé c'est
évidemment eux attendent qu'on les
rembourse vite et nous on attend qu'il
nous facture correctement donc en fait
on a mis en place un dispositif
d'accompagnement qui permet de nous
assurer à l'installation qu'un
professionnel de santé et en capacité de
nos facturer correctement donc ce qu'on
appelle plutôt un accompagnement
pédagogique et qui est renforcé
évidemment par des contrôles plus
modernes qu'on est en train d'intégrer
dans nos systèmes informations mais ça
c'est ton euros de map informatique
comme on l'a comme on les appelle et
donc qui sont des projets d'un peu plus
d'un peu plus long terme
la troisième brique c'est le contrôle et
la détection donc c'est comment est-ce
qu'on intègre là un peu plus de
d'intelligence dans nos outils de
contrôle pour avoir des ciblages
renforcés parce que le but du jeu c'est
pas non plus de nourrir une armée de
contrôleur chez nous pour aller
récupérer ce qui a été sorti comme
liquidité en tout cas pris en charge à
tort et puis le troisième volet c'est le
volet de de sanctions qu'on est une
sanction qui soit adaptée juste et puis
aussi rapide
donc ça voilà c'est les quatre briques 4
briques quatre briques fondamentales
et puis vous dire du coup qu'on est
évidemment engagé dans une dans une
structure en tout cas dans une
orientation de moyen terme avec un
certain nombre de priorités notamment
d'actualité et surconsommant hyperactif
bande organisé internet et les réseaux
sociaux qui sont des sujets qui par
ailleurs cause des dégâts parfois
médiatique quand on voit la facilité
avec laquelle certains trafics peuvent
avoir lieu et puis tout ce qui est
nouvelle pratique typiquement 100% santé
100 de santé et autres qui sont des
sujets sur lesquels on s'implique
fortement
sur les IPA pour partager les d'abord là
aussi le souhait de l'Assurance Maladie
de continuer à accompagner cette jeune
profession si j'ose dire c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons signé avec les
trois syndicats infirmiers libéraux en
juillet 2022 un nouvel avenant qui
améliore les financements de l'assurance
maladie à la fois dans le dans le
démarrage de l'activité des IPA qui est
souvent difficile et dans les niveaux de
forfaits qui ont augmenté de près de 20%
dans cette avenant donc la conviction
qu'il faut les accompagner que
d'ailleurs c'est une demande aussi de
beaucoup de médecins dans les maisons de
santé ou ailleurs généraliste comme
spécialiste et contrairement à ce qu'on
peut lire parfois et malheureusement
entendre également il y a une brève
volonté de travailler en commun de
beaucoup de médecins avec avec des IPA
aujourd'hui
comme je disais c'est encore une
profession jeune on a 220
IPA installés en libéral mais parce que
les flux de formation logiquement sont
encore à ce stade relativement limité
700 à 800 par an et que massivement
aujourd'hui elles vont plutôt à
l'hôpital ce qui est tout à fait tout à
fait normal et mais je crois là aussi
que le ministre les ministres de la
santé et de l'enseignement supérieur ont
on voilà souhaite pouvoir augmenter les
les les volumes de formation et nous
souhaitons notre côté continuer à mieux
accompagner les IPA dans à la phase
parcours de formation et ses premières
années d'exercice mais voilà l'état de
la situation aujourd'hui
très bien merci Monsieur le Directeur
alors donc nous avons neuf collègues qui
ont demandé la parole j'ai commencé par
Daniel Chassin
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le directeur pour vos propos
d'abord
juste quelques réflexions c'est par les
CPTs dans dans au niveau rural
c'est-à-dire avec plusieurs maisons de
santé réunir ces pts qu'on arrivera à
prendre des soins non programmées après
bien sûr c'est en fonction de la
négociation au niveau de des
consultations une réfection sur les IPA
si vous voulez le Sénat à
changer la loi Hirst pour que les IPA
soit uniquement coordonnées dans une
maison de santé et le fait de le mettre
dans une CPTs c'est un non sens complet
puisque lorsqu'une IPA va être appelé
par un client d'une autre maison de
santé alors qu'elle est dans une maison
de santé X et après par une maison de
santé y en direct ça va apporter
énormément de complications donc c'est
complètement un non-sens on peut en
pratique mais ça a été rectifié
donc ma question
si vous voulez c'est sur les infirmières
libérales les infirmières libérales si
vous voulez non pas été revalorisés
alors les actes médico-infirmiers 2009
le déplacement de 2011 les
infirmiers aux soins sont remplacés
maintenant par des bilans de soins
infirmiers enfin c'est d'une
complication incroyable mais en fait
dans les actes infirmiers aux soins par
exemple pour une personne de 96 ans qui
est qui n'est pas un continent mais qui
est dépendante et bien je rentre pas
dans les détails avec les ASI
l'infirmière aura 36 euros et avec un
BSI 16 dans la journée ce qui fait que
si vous voulez certaines infirmières qui
boient leur revenu baisser énormément et
bien
demande si avoir été alors que c'est des
infirmières on a un besoin absolument
très très important avec un
vieillissement de la population et une
prise en charge de la dépendance c'est
des gens si vous voulez qui sont
absolument indispensables dans les
maladies chroniques et la dépendance
donc je voulais savoir quand est-ce que
vous allez leur donner un petit peu
satisfaction en relevant donc le revenu
merci très bien la parole à ma largeur
merci monsieur le Président et bonjour
madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur
d'abord en quelques mots vous faites
face à un défi qui est quand même bien
complexe vous avez
dans votre analyse de des raisons de
l'échec avec dans la convention que
c'était le premier sujet de votre
audition vous avez dit ça sa capoter sur
les 30 euros mais bon c'est tout ce que
ce n'est que un marqueur en fait un
symptôme de quelque chose de plus
profond et là je pense que vraiment
étant nous nous ne sommes pas partis
prenante de cette discussion mais ayant
discuté avec les uns et les autres je
pense il y a quand même un vrai
malentendu sur l'histoire du travail et
plus pour gagner plus parce que vous
avez dit on demande on leur demande pas
de travailler plus mais si en fait et y
compris quand vous faites ce calcul qui
sur un plan techno est tout à fait jus
enfin mathématique pour pas employer de
mots à connotation
mathématiques et juste derrière tant de
patients en ALD sans médecin traitant il
y a tant de médecins traitant bah on
fait une règle de trois et puis voilà
chacun en printemps en plus mais c'est
leur demander donc de prendre plus de
patients et il me semble il me semble
qu'il y a un vrai changement à l'oeuvre
dans cette profession qui est qui date
pas d'hier qui est ancien mais qui se
développe qui est que ils ne veulent pas
travailler plus et qu'il travaille déjà
beaucoup et que ce travail est beaucoup
et aggravé par la pénurie je crois qu'on
a perdu à peu près 10000 médecins
traitant une dizaine d'années un peu de
choses près et donc le partage des
tâches et que c'est enfin bon je suis
pas tout balayé mais des solutions sont
mises en oeuvre pour essayer d'alléger
la charge mais la réalité c'est une
charge de travail importante c'est 52
heures en moyenne de travailler
hebdomadaire bon donc je crois qu'il y a
une vous faites face je vous dis ça je
n'ai pas la solution vous faites face à
une vraie difficulté à une et donc à une
distorsion dans la négociation d'une
assurance maladie qui défendant l'accès
aux soins juste titre et la nécessité de
de mieux répondre à la demande et des
patients qui ont des problèmes de santé
qui nécessitent un suivi régulier ont
besoin d'un médecin traitant et en face
un corps professionnel et Elisabeth
Doisneau l'a un peu dit aussi qui a une
forme aussi d'épuisement c'est-à-dire
ils veulent plus ils veulent plus à un
moment ils disent nous on en a marre on
veut et je porte pas de jugement
là-dessus une profession elle doit
évoluer tout le temps bien sûr mais je
constate que ce discours de on en a
marre on veut plus on veut plus de
nouvelles règles on veut plus est un
discours qui grandit dans cette
profession qui est une profession qui a
su en même temps beaucoup changer au
cours des dernières décennies moi
j'aurais trois questions à vous poser la
première c'est sur l'évolution des
dépenses mais en lien avec les
phénomènes qu'on voit actuellement vous
êtes vous vous tentez de piloter comme
l'a dit Corinne Imbert c'est 250
milliards de dépenses et on assiste à un
phénomène alors pour ça d'ailleurs
depuis 20 ans à peu près assurance
maladie a mis en place des parcours de
soins avec les organisations d'ailleurs
etc des façons d'essayer de réguler la
dépense et là on voit surgir une
financearisation qui touche les
établissements de santé privés depuis
très longtemps d'ailleurs il y a regardé
l'évolution du nombre d'adhérents de la
FHP qui a chuté des moyens d'une
concentration et de de développement des
groupes financiers mais maintenant ça
touche l'ambulatoire
l'imagerie est en train d'être prise en
main par des groupes et là il faut faire
de l'acte et il faut faire de l'acte et
beaucoup et c'est pas compliqué dans
l'imagerie et on va arriver ça dans
l'offre de soins primaire surfense sur
justement les difficultés dans les
territoires se multiplient les centres
de faces consultation voilà pardon pour
l'anglicisme mais on y va vous y allez
pour un problème essayez pas de parler
d'un autre truc chronique vous y allez
pour un problème aigu
tarif là 25 euros c'est bien payé
effectivement 30 pour les enfants voilà
et on débite de l'acte et puis on vient
de franchir vous le savez un nouveau
palier avec Love d'un groupe
d'abonnement la médecine de se pratique
pas comme un commerce il est interdit de
faire trois consultations pour le prix 2
on n'a pas le droit c'est toujours
interdit les pratiques commerciales mais
par contre là on prend un abonnement
alors ça coûte rien l'assurance maladie
qui ne le paye pas je sais très bien
mais on est en train de on est dans une
dérive financière et d'ubérisation de la
santé ma question elle est simple
comment est-ce que vous allez faire pour
maîtriser la dépense parce que si
l'abonnement de Ramsay vous ne le
remboursez pas et consultations derrière
vous allez payer et on sait le nombre de
téléconsultation que font notamment les
médecins quand ils sont en ligne
première question deuxième question sur
la fraude sociale je vais être bref elle
est majoritairement le fait des
professionnels bref que Monsieur le
Directeur vous souvenez je vous ai
interrogé il y a un an sur les fraudes à
légués de l'ihau Méditerranée en termes
de facturation et j'ai jamais reçu de
réponse malgré mes relances auprès de
vos collaborateurs depuis un an donc
j'aimerais savoir il s'agit de millions
d'euros si oui ou non une action et
entreprise pour récupérer ses fonds et
puis troisième question alors elle
dépasse un peu pardon la street
actualité mais comme on vous additionne
en général dans le cadre du PLFSS où on
est très cadré mais l'année dernière a
eu lieu un débat important qu'elles ont
la présidentielle sur la grande sécu
donc piste qui a été écartée mais qui
n'épuise pas du tout le sujet pour
l'Assurance Maladie évidemment pour
l'évolution des prochaines années
quel rôle vous voyez au complémentaire
je vous pose la question parce que la
Mutualité en particulier a mis sur la
table une proposition d'entrer dans la
santé au travail sujet dont on discute
et on discute sans cesse et la Mutualité
a produit tout un document en disant
on pourra avoir un rôle et participer au
financement de la santé au travail il y
a bien d'autres sujets qui peuvent être
mis sur la table mais est-ce que
l'assurance maladie poursuit les
réflexions est-ce que vous souhaitez
rester dans votre périmètre actuel
est-ce que vous avez une réflexion
particulière sur une meilleure
articulation on va dire parce que qu'on
soit ou pas favorable à la grande sécu
et à consensus pour dire que le système
actuel est quand même pas tout à fait
efficient en termes de place des
organismes complémentaires
j'avais une question sur la Ld mais elle
a déjà été posée vous avez en partie
répondu mais est-ce que l'objectif était
assez ambitieux fixé par le ministre de
la Santé est-ce que vous avez un une
évaluation au fil de l'eau de de
finalement de cette appariment entre les
personnes en ALD et les médecins
traitant est-ce que ça est-ce que ça
fonctionne vous nous avez pas donné de
chiffre précis et puis
mon autre question concerne la
prolifération de cabines de
téléconsultation en supermarché on
envoie de plus en plus Monoprix Leclerc
mais surtout aussi dans nos communes
rurales ou c'est vraiment exponentiel
moi je vois dans mon département et
enfin c'est une multiplication
heureusement je dirais à moindre
difficulté dans les pharmacies mais pour
autant je voulais savoir quel était
votre regard sur ces sur ces
installations la cabine de
téléconsultation qui sont en fait des
cabines one shot qui peuvent rendre un
service dans les déserts médicaux et
apparaître comme une solution pour les
déserts médicaux moi je suis pas
convaincue que ça en soit une parce que
c'est une consultation avec des
consommations récurrentes d'ailleurs par
les mêmes patients et et pas de vision
globale de la situation médicale du
patient donc je voulais savoir comment
et quelle limite on pouvait aussi mettre
à ces proliférations et puis une autre
question
sur mon espace
santé.fr donc nous travaillons avec
madame la Présidente sur les données de
santé
le préalable à une utilisation et une
bonne exploitation des données de santé
c'est déjà que mon espace santé.fr soit
renseigné donc où on en est sur cette
utilisation d'une part par le patient
mais aussi par
les professionnels de santé qu'on a vu
hier pour l'Ordre des médecins et des
infirmiers et bon ça nous a laissé un
petit peu enfin moi un peu perplexe par
rapport à l'ambition du gouvernement sur
le sujet merci bien on prend encore deux
collègues
Jean-Marie René Paul Savary ensuite
monsieur fatum répondre merci merci
Madame Présidente je suis le directeur
général je reviens sur le sujet de la
fraude vous en doutiez d'ailleurs
certainement
il y a un an peut-être à peu près vous
nous avions annoncé quelques chiffres
je le souvenir d'un 15 milliards
disons de des dépenses qui avaient été
estimé
au terme enfin en terme de fraude
avec je dirais j'avais noté ce chiffre
de mémoire environ 500 millions de
détectés
puis vous nous avez dit on a un plan
parce que c'est évidemment ça concerne
beaucoup de professions est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner aujourd'hui d'autres
évaluations d'autres estimations pour
les autres professions concernées
des infirmiers les médecins généralistes
les médecins hospitaliers les hôpitaux
je sais que les hôpitaux vous les aviez
laissés un peu à part
quel est le plan
dans quel délai aurons-nous tous ces
chiffres pour éviter ce qu'on lit ce
qu'on entend je ne veux pas critiquer la
Cour des comptes elle a lancé elle-même
aussi des chiffres moi j'attends
effectivement de votre part des
précisions que vous nous aviez proposé
annoncé et vous nous aviez indiqué que
nous les aurions dans l'année qui suit
on y est alors deuxième question si vous
me permettez concerne le
la le plan de lutte de la fraude sociale
qui a été lancé par le ministre des
comptes publics
ce sont communiqués de presse le
gouvernement lance une mission de
préfiguration pour examiner la fusion
entre la carte nationale d'identité et
la carte Vitale or il y a un rapport de
Liga c'est l'IGF d'avril d'ailleurs 2023
donc il y a peu qui indiquent que vous
avez fait part de votre effort réserve à
ce sujet alors est-ce que vous pouvez
nous préciser votre point de vue et nous
dire s'il existe selon vous une
véritable désaccord avec le gouvernement
et quels sont la véritables pistes à
suivre et je dirais d'une façon plus
générale
qu'elle appréciation vous portez sur le
plan d'action du gouvernement merci
beaucoup
le Savary
on a l'impression de poser les mêmes
questions d'avoir les mêmes réponses
ça évolue pas aussi vite que ça les
astres dont etc c'est toujours pareil
bon
vous commentez pas le nombre de
conventionnements vous avez raison il y
en a pas beaucoup mais vous inquiétez
pas vous en aurez beaucoup plus dans
dans les mois qui viennent et je partage
tout à fait l'inquiétude de Bernard
Chaumier parce que c'est en train de
s'organiser c'est en train de
s'organiser au détriment des patients au
détriment de l'assurance maladie et de
façon très commerciale beaucoup plus
commercial que que
solidaire
je voulais savoir quand même ce que vous
pensez des des centres de soins non
programmés de la Fédération des centres
de soins non programmés
quelque chose
d'intéressant des respons des médecins
qui se prennent en main et qui assure
cela sans faire partie justement de
groupe
soyons attentifs peut-être à soutenir ce
type de démarche qui a une démarche
solitaire et non pas commercial par
rapport aux démarches de de groupe et
puis une autre question plus technique
sur la cause la colle
la convention d'objectif et de gestion
n'a pas été
n'a pas été reporté
qu'en est-il de
cons sont-ils de vos moyens pour faire
en sorte que la caisse d'Assurance
Maladie puisse se répondre à toutes ces
interrogations qu'en est-il donc de la
coche 2023 2027 qui a ma connaissance
n'a pas été
signé
je vous rejoins sur l'intérêt de de
bien articuler l'intervention des
notamment des IPA avec avec les
exercices coordonnées c'est notamment le
point d'aboutissement vous l'avez évoqué
législatives de de la loi dit triste
sur les infirmières libérales
partage à nouveau avec vous
l'importance de pouvoir soutenir les un
peu plus 100000 infirmières libérales
qui en effet
sont des acteurs primordial de la prise
en charge de des assurés notamment à
domicile des personnes âgées pas que
mais beaucoup
de points peut-être d'abord vous dire
que
au-delà de la de l'acte ou de du
déplacement l'assurance maladie à ces
dernières années fortement soutenu la
profession notamment au travers du
déploiement du bilan de Soins Infirmier
du BSI qui permet de mieux rémunérer
l'intervention des infirmières libérales
à domicile je ferai des personnes âgées
c'est 2500 euros de plus par infirmière
libérale par an 2500 euros de plus par
infirmière libérale par an que permet le
BSI donc c'est un nouveau mode de
paiement plus forfaitaire mais c'est
aussi d'un investissement supplémentaire
de l'assurance maladie et par ailleurs
je vous indique que
conformément au mandats qui nous a été
fixé par le ministre de la Santé de la
prévention il y a une quinzaine de jours
d'ouvrir des négociations un peu flash
avec quatre professions paramédicales
nous avançons je crois très positivement
avec les infirmières libérales pour
notamment débouchés possiblement sur une
augmentation des indemnités de
déplacement et que j'espère d'ici la fin
de la semaine pouvoir aboutir donc vous
voyez ce sont des négociations qui
avancent très rapidement et qui
permettront en effet de soutenir les
infirmières libérales qui sont la
profession qui se déplace le plus au
domicile des patients
ce sénateur Chaumier
évidemment beaucoup de beaucoup de
choses à dire sur
l'état de la profession
médicale
et la nécessité d'être à l'écoute sans
doute à la fois d'une
génération plus ancienne qui
a travaillé beaucoup continuer à
travailler beaucoup et légitimement ne
sonne pas travailler davantage et sans
les opposer sans caricaturer une jeune
génération qui n'a pas envie
complètement d'adopter le même modèle je
crois qu'on le vit chacune et chacun à
peu près comme ça même si c'est
évidemment très très
résumé
et donc il faut être à l'écoute de ça
c'est la raison pour laquelle je redis à
nouveau que l'enjeu non je n'ai pas de
faire travailler plus l'enjeu est de
répondre à une réalité qui est celle que
nous connaissons qui est moins de
médecin plus de patients et donc comment
nous accompagnons ces professionnels sur
deux mouvements d'ailleurs que
malheureusement souvent c'est plus
d'exercices coordonnées plus de
délégation de tâches plus de transfert
de stage sur des choses simples et plus
de soutien au médecin traitant pour leur
permettre de prendre en charge plus de
patients mais je redis ma conviction que
c'est possible
d'accompagner les médecins libéraux pour
qu'ils prennent plus de patients sans
qu'ils ne travaillent plus c'est
possible c'est plus de maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire objectif 4000 maisons
de santé publique et la dynamique elle
est très significative elle est très
significative sur les MSP je voyais en
trois ans le nombre on a aujourd'hui
près de 15% des médecins généralistes
qui travaillent en maison de santé ça va
très très vite et c'est un exercice qui
leur donne des meilleurs conditions de
travail et qui permet de prendre en
charge plus de passion et de ce point de
vue là aussi je partage avec vous que il
y a une dynamique aussi à l'oeuvre
que peut-être on entend moins qui
s'exprime moins mais la dynamique des
CPTs elle est réel et c'est des médecins
avec d'autres professionnels de santé
qui les créent la dynamique des maisons
de santé elle est réelle si on a 4500 à
600 médicaux aujourd'hui c'est que les
médecins s'emballent de ces solutions
donc il y a aussi beaucoup de médecins
sur le territoire mais vous le savez qui
s'empare de ces outils qui construisent
des réponses qu'on doit soutenir et je
pense que c'est important de le faire
m'interrogez sur la financearisation
c'est un sujet de préoccupation pour
l'assurance maladie
on l'a éprouvé très directement dans les
négociations avec le secteur de la
biologie médicale qui a fini par aboutir
mais dans des conditions difficiles et
ces difficultés ne sont pas étrangères à
la financarisation de ce secteur
nous sommes extrêmement attentifs à ce
qui peut se passer d'un autre domaine
dans la radiologie
dans les soins primaires nous essaierons
de faire un certain nombre de d'éléments
de diagnostic et de proposition dans le
dans le rapport chargé produit que nous
sur lequel nous travaillons et que nous
proposerons au Conseil de la CNAM à la
fin du mois de juin au début du mois de
juillet
parce qu'en effet autant ils sûrement
inutile de caricaturer que nous avons
besoin d'acteurs publics privés privés
lucratif privé démocratique non lucratif
autant les dérives de la
financièreisation sont problématiques et
de ce point de vue là j'ai eu l'occasion
de rappeler à la fois que bien se redire
que l'offre de RAM c'est ni près ni de
loin n'était financé par l'assurance
maladie ni les abonnements ni les
consultations rien de ce système n'est
remboursé par l'assurance maladie alors
évidemment c'est une prescription
derrière comme pour un médecin non
conventionné comme on pourra mettre sa
retraité ou comme pour un médecin qui
fait un acte gratuit ça la prescription
est prise en charge mais nous ne
finançons pas ce système et je j'en
profite pour souligner que un tel
dispositif pour nous ne répond pas à une
assurance maladie solidaire un système
de santé solidaire à une organisation
d'un système de soins qui ne doit pas
dépendre de la capacité des gens à payer
un abonnement et que il y a quand même
une grande différence entre le recourir
aux soins et se un abonnement
téléphonique ou un abonnement à Netflix
il serait utile qu'on ne mélange pas des
choses
dernièrement deux derniers éléments vous
m'avez interrogé sur les contrôles sur
l'iachu je vous indique que des
contrôles sont en cours actuellement sur
l'iachu pour vérifier les sujets de
tarification
tout en rappelant que s'agissant de
contrôle tarifaire
cet établissement comme l'ensemble des
établissements étaient en garantie de
financement en 2020 en 2021 2022 donc
qui explique le fait que ces contrôles
ont une portée mécaniquement limitée
néanmoins ils en ont une en matière de
par complémentaire et donc nous nous
sommes en train nous avons engagé des
contrôles et nous partagerons évidemment
les les résultats dès lors qu'ils auront
abouti vous m'interrogez sur les
relations à moi MC des sujets grandes
sécu très rapidement je suis pour ma
part convaincu de l'intérêt et de la
nécessité d'un partenariat renforcé
entre assurance maladie obligatoire
assurance maladie complémentaire et les
professionnels de santé
de ce point de vue là redira nouveau je
crois les progrès qui ont été permis par
le 100% santé qui a permis ces progrès
sont inégaux mais qui ont permis de
faire progresser l'accès aux soins de
nos concitoyens dans beaucoup de
domaines très importants et partagez
avec vous que nous avons engagé avec les
complémentaires santé et avec les
professionnels de santé en l'occurrence
les libéraux des discussions sur les
soins dentaires sur lesquels nous
voulons poursuivre sa dynamique voir si
nous pouvons l'amplifier faire davantage
de prévention
dans un effort conjoint avec les
complémentaires santé et je crois
davantage en cette sans mauvais jeu de
mots cette complémentarité en tout cas
ce travail coordonné pour améliorer
l'accès aux soins améliorer la
prévention un certain nombre de
complémentaires en effet ont des
capacités d'intervention en entreprise
que nous n'avons pas tout à fait en tout
cas voilà et de ce point de vue là c'est
plutôt dans ce sens là que nous voulons
travailler
madame le héros sur les objectifs est-ce
que le jeu est-ce que l'objectif est
assez ambitieux sur le plan d'action LD
125 ans je pense honnêtement il est
parce qu'en réalité voilà nous faisons
face à une dynamique forte qui fait
qu'on a plus de malades chroniques on a
plus de patients à régler qu'on a moins
de médecin traitant et donc le fait de
de stopper cette courbe des des patients
sans mettre un traitant qui était 600
000 début 2022 700 000 à la fin de
l'année 2022 ici on fait rien 800000 à
la fin de l'année 2023 je pense que cet
objectif de de d'arrêter l'hémorragie si
j'ose dire il est ambitieux on fera le
plan est quand même assez encore récent
il est en train de se déployer donc il
est trop tôt pour donner des chiffres
nous voulons nous mettre progressivement
dans un dans un suivi trimestriel de de
des résultats et donc je pense que dans
les prochaines semaines on pourra faire
deux premiers bilans vous m'interrogez
sur la téléconsultation
simplement partager mais en lien avec ce
que je disais tout à l'heure au
sénateurs jauniers sur la sur la
financearisation sur la régulation
notre souhait que
la téléconsultation trouve davantage une
place régulée dans le parcours de soins
de ce point de vue là nous participons
aux travaux pilotés par le ministère de
la Santé de la prévention sur l'article
53 de la loi de financement pour
2023 qui prévoit un cahier des charges
sur les plateformes de téléconsultation
qui doit permettre d'intégrer des
exigences de de qualité de transparence
d'éthique je ne crois pas qu'il y ait
une place justifiée à des télécabines
dans des supermarchés ou dans des lieux
qui ne correspondent pas à un exercice
normal de ce qui s'appelle un accès aux
soins et les études que nous avons
menées et que les équipes du ministère
de la Santé ont monnaie ont montré à ce
stade dans tous les cas que la
téléconsultation
n'était aujourd'hui pas par recours plus
important que que d'autres dans les
déserts médicaux même si on peut
imaginer que il faut pas balayer non
plus d'un revers de la main un tel un
tel une telle utilisation vous
m'interrogez sur mon espace Mon Espace
Santé partager avec vous que la
dynamique
ce poursuit à la fois en termes de
d'activation des des espaces santé
puisque on est aujourd'hui un peu moins
de 9 millions de profils activés un peu
plus de 200 000 par mois nous pensons
que ça dynamique va s'accélérer dès lors
que nous nous serons allés au bout de ce
qui est en cours c'est-à-dire
l'équipement de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé et notamment les
médecins de ville les laboratoires de
biologie et de radiologie et les
hôpitaux en termes sur les logiciels
Ségur qui vont permettre de brancher les
canaux d'alimentation
des espaces santé des DMP pour les
professionnels de santé et ça va
accentuer la dynamique d'alimentation et
donc de consultation des espaces santé
mais d'ores et déjà tout de même
partager avec vous que on a aujourd'hui
plus de 67 millions de documents
alimentaires dans les DMP et une très
forte accélération ces derniers mois et
donc nous pensons que cette dynamique va
se poursuivre
s'agissant de la
fraude sénateur je vous confirme que
nous poursuivons nos travaux
d'évaluation puisque le rapport de la
Cour des comptes d'ailleurs en fait état
aujourd'hui ces travaux ont été
finalisés sur la C2S sur les médecins
généralistes sur les transporteurs
sanitaires sur les infirmiers sur les
masters kinés et sur les pharmaciens
et donc ces travaux là sont déjà achevés
certains nombre d'entre eux doivent
encore être partagés avec des
professionnels concernés et donc nous
poursuivrons avec
une fin de ces travaux j'espère à la fin
de l'année 2023 ou au début de l'année
2024 et voilà nous nous poursuivrons ces
travaux de manière intense
en veillant aussi au dialogue avec les
professions
concernées mais c'était tout de même une
démarche nouvelle je crois de la part de
l'assurance maladie et qui est
les chiffres sont dans le rapport de la
Cour des comptes donc je peux vous
donner les fourchettes professions par
profession au sujet par sujet donc la
C2S la fourchette est entre 25 et 176
millions d'euros pour les médecins
généralistes entre 185 et 215 millions
d'euros pour les transporteurs
sanitaires entre 145 et 177 millions
d'euros pour les infirmiers entre 286 et
393 millions d'euros pour les MASTER
cleaner entre 91 et 105 millions d'euros
pour les pharmaciens entre 166 et 234
millions d'euros donc ces chiffres sont
ce sont des estimations de la fraude
voilà de la fraude voilà nous nous
menons un travail sur la base de
l'extrapolation de nos résultats par
rapport à une estimation du phénomène de
la fraude en elle-même et nous allons
poursuivre sur les autres professions
vos méthodes ensuite de redressement de
de cette fraude notamment avec des
méthodes
algorithmiques etc est-ce que ça se met
en place on a parlé effectivement d'une
augmentation importante du nombre de
contrôleurs je crois que vu les chiffres
il me paraît vraiment intéressant de
multiplier les contrôles avec les outils
que vous mettez au point bien sûr en
tout cas je
vous confirme que ça ça voilà ça
justifie je l'ai dit un investissement
renforcé déjà objectif en augmentation
ça justifie également des augmentations
d'effectifs dédiées à lutte contre
l'afro de le ministre des comptes
publics a évoqué pour l'ensemble des
branches de la sécurité sociale le
chiffre de 1000
contrôleur supplémentaires en matière de
lutte contre la fraude ça me permet de
répondre à une question de Monsieur
Savary monsieur sénateur sur la coche
qui n'est pas encore totalement
bouclée avec l'étal et les discussions
se finalise
je l'espère dans les tous prochains
jours ou les toutes prochaines petites
semaines
mais euh les sous-jacents de la
trajectoire qui se dessine nous
permettront de renforcer nos moyens de
manière importante en matière de lutte
contre la fraude
c'est certain faute de quoi nous
obtiendrons pas les résultats que nous
nous sommes objectifs que nous nous
sommes fixés encore une fois 500
millions d'euros à l'horizon 2024 c'est
un peu moins de deux fois plus
le résultat de 2019 donc c'est un
objectif ambitieux
m'avait interrogé également sur le sujet
de la mise en place d'un scénario de qui
rapprochait à la carte vitale de la
carte d'identité électronique le
ministre a annoncé en effet le principe
d'une mission interministériale pour
instruire un tel scénario ça me permet
de préciser que si vous
prenez connaissance de de du rapport de
Liga CGF sur la carte Vitale biométrique
et de la réponse que j'ai pu apporter
vous y verrez que je pose deux éléments
qui n'ont pas été toujours repris
premièrement l'importance que j'attache
c'est que l'assurance maladie attache à
la lutte contre la fraude à l'identité
et
à la vérification de l'existence de
droit à l'assurance maladie qui justifie
la prise en charge c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous opérons des traitements
statistiques plus de 70 millions de
traitements statistiques par an près
d'un 5 millions de contrôles individuels
autour de la protection universelle
maladie et de ce sujet de la lutte
contre la fausse à la identité est un
sujet important et deuxième point je
j'évoquais également dans ma réponse la
nécessité que les avantages et les
inconvénients d'un tel scénario soit
soigneusement analysé c'est ce que fera
la mission
interministérielle qui va être lancée et
à laquelle l'assurance maladie
contribuera
voilà je crois ce qui peut permettre
d'apporter un certain nombre de réponses
ce sénateur Savary sur les centres de
soins non programmés
ça fait le lien un peu avec la réponse
que je j'ai essayé de partager avec le
sénateur geomier
notre je pense que c'est centre devrait
rester subsidiaire
subsidiaire au médecin traitant
subsidiaire a une équipe de soins autour
des médecins traitants et à éviter d'en
faire un premier mode de recours aux
soins parce que c'est un recours
ponctuel parce que ça va être un recours
qui marquer rarement une continuité dans
la prise en charge et que par ailleurs
il y a un risque important comme pour la
téléconstration comme pour ces formules
d'abonnement que en réalité nous
contribuons à détruire du temps médical
disponible pourquoi être médecin
traitant toute la semaine exercée
difficile prendre en charge des patients
jeunes moins jeunes prendre du temps si
en réalité il vous suffit de travailler
deux jours par semaine dans un centre de
soins non programmés une demi-journée
dans un centre de téléconsultation et
d'avoir un niveau de rémunération
comparable c'est ça qui le danger qui
nous guette c'est ça le danger qui nous
guette c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle voilà notre souhait de soutenir
les médecins traitants
[Musique]
de soutenir leur rémunération
et important si nous ne répondons sinon
ne répondons que par l'acte s'il ne
répondons que par l'acte
alors
nous soutiendrons autant les
consultations dans les soins non
programmés que chez les médecins
traitant donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle et je crois que c'était le sens
de de la question
tout à l'heure de se dire qu'il y a
différents leviers de rémunération et
que si nous ancrons si nous soutenons
fortement les médecins traitant lors
d'une donneront envie aux médecins
généralistes d'exercer cette fonction et
peut-être moins de monter des sortes de
soins non programmés qui optimisent une
forme de consommation de soin qui n'est
pas complètement notre tasse de thé
monsieur fantôme soyez moins timide sur
les médecins
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur général les médecins vont mal
mais il est patients vont très mal aussi
donc ils appellent au secours l'accès
aux soins c'est vraiment une difficulté
majeure maintenant partout sur le
territoire national et face à cela ça a
été dit par plusieurs collègues c'est
très compliqué de mener les négociations
d'ailleurs elles ont échouées parce que
les médecins en général vont mal aussi
donc c'est bien un contexte par
reprendre ce qu'on dit nos collègues il
n'est pas que c'est pas qu'une question
d'argent vous le savez bien mais
d'autres sujets qui vont mal une crise
passion générale et les derniers textes
et puis ceux à venir
ont peut-être encore compliqué la
situation parce que il y a une crise
passion encore plus forte de ce que
j'entends de mes échanges il y a deux
sujets qui reviennent régulièrement le
sujet de la délégation de tâches et le
sujet des installations des contraintes
à l'installation alors sur la délégation
de tâches j'ai deux petites remarques on
a parlé des IPA c'est très bien
accompagné les hyper moi sur mon
territoire il y en a qui souhaiteraient
faire cette formation mais il faudrait
aussi les accompagner pendant le temps
de leur formation parce que c'est
compliqué pendant deux ans on vit
comment
sur le sujet de la délégation par
exemple aux infirmiers on a beaucoup
parlé des infirmiers ils vont très mal
également parce que autant mon collègues
jeuniers ont dit les médecins ne veulent
plus les infirmiers veulent plus non
plus et qui ne veulent plus non plus
enfin le problème c'est que plus
personne ne va bien
donc je suis très content d'apprendre
que les négociations flash avec les
infirmiers pourraient aboutir parce que
c'est vraiment vraiment quelque chose
d'important malgré tout ça permet de
d'effler un deuxième sujet c'est la
complexité de la tarification qui
devient complètement
ubuesque et qui fait que peut-être au
moment des négociations c'est difficile
d'avoir une visibilité sur réellement
les augmentations que ils vont percevoir
parce que c'est c'est complètement
délirant la tarification j'ai une
inquiétude aussi sur le maillage des
pharmacies en milieu rural parce que
c'est essentiel et il est très fragile
alors sur les
installations disons
encadrés des médecins généralistes moi
personnellement je pense qu'on risque de
recriper encore beaucoup la situation
avec une profession qui est pas déjà
très allante du coup peut-être que si on
pouvait s'appuyer sur des chiffres vous
nous avez parlé des 700 000 patients à
LD qui n'ont pas de médecin traitant
est-ce qu'on a une répartition
géographique de ces patients qui
permettrait de voir si c'est pertinent
ou pas de tordre le bras au médecin
généraliste au moment de leur
installation merci
bien Jean-Luc fischet madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Directeur général
je voulais reprendre effectivement la
question des la situation des
infirmières infirmiers libéraux mais
vous y avez répondu en partie le
deuxième volet concerne la question de
la fraude moi je suis quand même assez
surpris de voir comment on peut parler
tout à fait sereinement de la fraude
depuis de nombreuses années sans y
apporter remède il y a quand même un
vrai souci là il saisit de l'argent des
des assurés sociaux je ne suis pas
vraiment favorable algorithmes mais je
pense que aujourd'hui l'intelligence
artificielle les algorithmes font que on
a des moyens en amont de contrôler
toutes ces affaires là et de s'équiper
de moyens c'est-à-dire que il y a pas un
secteur professionnel aujourd'hui qui
n'a pas des algorithmes qui permet de
surveiller les salariés les dépenses les
délivrons etc donc on peut imaginer que
la sécurité sociale parait aussi
s'équiper d'un matériel qui permette non
pas de travailler sur l'évaluation de la
fraude puisque l'évaluation de l'afro
dans la connaît mais d'éviter la fraude
carrément puisqu'il s'agit quand même de
de milliards qui pourraient être
consacré à autre chose donc j'aimerais
vraiment avoir des réponses là-dessus et
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on nous donne des
signes de soucis d'efficacité pour
empêcher la fraude et ça c'est un point
très très important le deuxième le
deuxième ma deuxième question
concerne la question du du
déconventionnement vous nous disiez tout
à l'heure qu'il y a 12 médecins qui ont
pardon 22
de médecins qui se sont déconventionnés
j'aimerais savoir si c'est médecin sont
sur un territoire précis parce que le
décorationnement suppose que un certain
nombre de personnes n'ont plus accès à
leur médecin puisque ils ne sont pas
remboursés il y a aussi un autre point
qui concerne le fait qu'il y a
aujourd'hui un centre de médecin
généraliste qui facture la consultation
à 30 euros et je crois que ça se propage
qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce que c'est
dans ces cas là un remboursement à
hauteur de la facturation enfin quelle
est la position de la sécurité sociale
sur cette affaire de sciences réalise
sur cette affaire là je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente je trouve
monsieur fantôme très optimiste sur les
négociations médicales parce que moi de
ce que j'entends sur mon sur mon terrain
c'est que les médecins se sentent
humiliés à consulter à 26,50 €. beaucoup
vont arrondir à 30 euros je vous le
confirme
il y a d'autres chiffres quand même
beaucoup plus inquiétant on annonce pour
2022 une surmortalité de 54
000 personnes qui n'étaient vraiment pas
attendues bon il y a peut-être l'effet
après covid mais bon est-ce que
finalement là on va pas dès maintenant
avoir cette cette
hémorragie de décès qui qui risque de
vraiment
prendre le pas sur la simple négociation
médicale qui paraît vraiment ridicule
par rapport à cette à cette surmortalité
au fait que les gens ne se soignent plus
on a également
j'aimerais que vous nous donniez un
chiffre sur la consommation médicament
en particulier en automédication
puisqu'on entend parler de tramadol et
d'autres opiacés qui sont surconsommés
depuis deux ans avec les conséquences
délétères qu'on connaît
vous avez parlé de l'assistant médical
ou de l'assistante médicale je voudrais
savoir si dans le cadre des négociations
en passant en augmentant 2,50 les
médecins auront les moyens de se de se
doter d'assistants médicaux est-ce que
c'est eux qui sont chargés de salariés
ces assistants ou est-ce que la CPAM
intervient et je vais aller sur un point
de détail sur les sur les dentistes il
manque de dentiste partout de façon un
peu innovante certains le doyen de
l'université de Bordeaux propose une
délocalisation de formation des
étudiants or les hôpitaux dans lesquels
sont formés ces étudiants comment ça
dire que ces étudiants ne sont pas
rentables donc est-ce que finalement on
a un vrai désir d'améliorer les choses
et de donner des moyens là où les idées
sont bonnes ou est-ce que vous êtes de
votre côté les médecins maintenant sont
montrés du doigt parce qu'ils veulent
plus travailler parce que pour 26-50 il
devrait faire beaucoup plus etc ce qu'on
ne va pas vers une vers un exercice
salarié généralisé puisque les jeunes
enfin moi je vois pas un jeune à
s'installer dans ces conditions là le
vieux médecin de mon âge qui qui
travaille toujours lui il y a longtemps
qu'il a payé son cabinet médical et puis
il est il est fidèle à sa patientèle
mais le jeûne vous je pense pas que ça
soit un bon signal de lui proposer une
consultation à 26 50 voilà
oui merci
Monsieur directeur général c'est
beaucoup de sujets ont été évoqués vont
par les collègues et parler des
questions jusqu'à présent on sait que le
bon le désert médicaux c'est la question
récurrente dans tous nos territoires
certaines pistes ont été mises en place
suite aux diverses propositions de loi
notamment les acides médicaux et
également les les infirmières en
pratique avancées bien que dans certains
territoires il n'y a peu de formation je
parle à mon département il y a qu'une
infirmière en pratique avancée qui qui
disons est formé à ce à ce nouveau
statut
on ne on assiste aussi dans des
départements dans des régions je parle
je pense avant le département aussi aux
salariat par l'intermédiaire des centres
territoriaux de santé salut c'est le
conseil départemental qui finance des
médecins salariés donc c'est assez
demandé à côté de du fait que des
médecins étrangers viennent conforter
disons la demande de danser dans ces
territoires enfin il a été évoqué
Elisabet dono c'était un chiffre sur la
la fraude en cette matière de entre
quatre et cinq milliards d'euros enfin
moi je le trouve énorme puisqu'il s'agit
de plus de 2% du budget d'assurance
maladie et pratiquement d'un pour ça du
budget total de la sécurité sociale donc
vous avez parlé Monsieur le Directeur
Général d'évaluation donc quels sont les
les remèdes aussi les outils que vous
avez utilisés pour essayer de remédier à
ce genre de fraude bien sûr il y a
plusieurs éléments en matière de fraude
bon je voyais ces jours-ci bon des
personnes qui me disaient voilà je suis
au chômage je vais me faire établir un
certificat médical de un mois pour
repousser les droits vous voyez un
exemple parmi bien d'autres bien sûr
merci
Michel meunier te met à la présidente
merci Michel directeur général de votre
présentation
la question de la du contrôle est une
question qui intéresse beaucoup la
commission des affaires sociales puisque
vous le savez l'année dernière sur un
autre sujet le médico-social avec mon
collègue Bernard bonne nous avons
travaillé ces aspects et votre triptyque
vous nous présentez contrôle
accompagnement pédagogique et sanctions
nous va très bien puisque c'est ce que
nous prenions en l'espèce en y rajoutant
la dépendance
l'interdépendance avec les autres corps
d'inspection et c'est important je pense
notamment
au domaine du travail au domaine de la
répression des fraudes voilà donc
est-ce que vous pourriez parce que vous
l'avez dit rapidement nous dire
concrètement qui contrôle quels moyens
vous avez vous avez donné un chiffre de
création mais concrètement
est-ce que ce sont des inspecteurs
dédiés au contrôle qui font
contrôle ou est-ce que ce sont des
agents qui en plus de leur travail
quotidien sont amenés à faire ces
contrôles je vais vous donner un exemple
précis parce que dans le domaine du
médico-social dans les EHPAD l'année
dernière a été inspecté cette île 1500
EHPAD est-ce que nous ce qui était
recherché c'était les écarts entre les
affectations
du de tout ce qui était hébergement avec
la sécurité sociale et on l'a découvert
parfois la sécu était amenée à payer des
dépenses qu'elle n'avait pas du tout à
rembourser un exemple sur l'alimentaire
il était plus facile de donner des
compléments alimentaires remboursés par
la Sécurité Sociale qu'une portion
supplémentaire de fromage par exemple
aux résidents donc en un an qu'est-ce
qu'il a été observé qu'elles
enseignements vous tirez et quelle
sanctions ont été données merci
sol on va prendre toutes les questions
parce que je crois que ma Fatuma un
engagement
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur mais mes chers collègues moi
j'ai face au défi là auquel nous sommes
confrontés plus de patients moins de
médecins certains médecins retraités
acceptent si vous voulez d'apporter leur
pierre donc à l'édifice et de consacrer
un petit peu de leur temps à la prise en
charge donc de certains de nos
administrer sur des territoires en
particulier où la désertification est
amplifiée certains acceptent de d'offrir
enfin de travailler une demi-journée
d'autres une journée d'autres un jour et
demi
or il est opposé par vos services en
tout cas
localement c'est deux jours et demi ou
c'est rien alors je voudrais connaître
votre positionnement en la matière et
savoir si vous envisagez un
assouplissement de ces règles si tenter
qu'il y ait des règles en la matière je
vous remercie
beaucoup de questions étaient posées
mais l'une d'entre elles a attiré mon
attention c'est celle posée par Bernard
jaumier à laquelle j'adhère complètement
sur la financièreisation de la santé au
niveau du territoire national et je
voudrais vous dire dans mon département
le Vaucluse il y a quelques endroits qui
sont des déserts médicaux mais dans
l'ensemble on a quand même pas à se
plaindre par rapport à d'autres
départements or malgré cela quand je
passe sur la RN7 entre ma ville et ma
permanence je vois une pharmacie mais
pas gérée par des pharmaciens géré par
un groupe sur lequel il y a une grande
affiche ici nous avons une cabine de
téléconsultation grande affiche alors ce
matin sur France Info
je regarde la télé de temps en temps
pour me mettre au courant d'informations
publicité sur parafferma publicité sur
le groupe Ramsay publicité sur des
groupes mutualistes qui prennent en
charge la santé etc alors il me semble
que pour les professionnels de santé la
publicité est interdite est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas
je vais poser la question autrement si
le Sénat tout groupe confondu faisait
une proposition de loi interdisant la
publicité en matière de santé pour tout
le monde est-ce qu'on aurait votre
accord
la victoire jasmin on fait des lois sans
quand même demander la corde à CNAM
et ensuite
et ensuite ce sera emiliane Pomerol oui
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
alors j'ai trois questions alors
concernant les disparités en outre-mer
les disparités concernant l'installation
des médecins et l'absence même dans
certaines zones de médecins traitant il
y a beaucoup de personnes qui n'ont pas
qui n'ont malheureusement pas ou plus
d'un médecin Triton ça c'est la question
ça a été dit bon c'est une question
d'aménagement du territoire mais aussi
une insuffisance du nombre de médecins
l'idée de prise en charge sont très
importants alors il y a effectivement
ces difficultés là mais il y a également
les problèmes qui se posent concernant
les évacuations sanitaires qui génère
des secours important de la mesure où il
y a quand même des archipels en
Guadeloupe par exemple ou c'est un
archipel avec des
îles du Sud ou il y a pas une offre
suffisante et pour des soins qui
pourraient être avec des cours maîtrisés
et bien on a des sucs qu'on
considérables parce qu'il y a les frais
d'avion ou l'hélicoptère quelquefois
donc ça c'est quand même quelque chose à
prendre en compte et pour certains
autres soins par manque de spécialistes
et bien il y a des déplacements vers ici
même l'Hexagone les hôpitaux parisiens
donc ce qui génère également des secours
complémentaires et des difficultés pour
les familles parce qu'il y a des
difficultés pour la prise en charge des
personnes pour les enfants quelquefois
également malheureusement de cancer donc
des secours pour le déplacement de
femmes des familles et pour les
personnes qui doivent travailler qui
sont seuls quelques fois des familles
parentales et bien là aussi c'est
compliqué donc il y a également des
difficultés concernant la psychiatrie et
la pédopsychiatrie a nécessité d'avoir
une
pédopsychiatrie parce qu'il y a en
Guadeloupe parce que ça n'existe pas
mais il y a de vrais problèmes également
de prévention donc à sa générations
considérable parce qu'il y a des
déplacements avec
de la sécurité sociale c'est vrai mais
tout ce déplacements génère des secours
et d'autre part la question des jeunes
médecins
ultramarins beaucoup de jeunes font des
études ils commencent chez nous et ils
continuent ici dans l'Hexagone et
quelques fois il vient le revenir par
malheureusement ils n'ont pas la
priorité alors ça génère des sucres
considérable et ce sera ça sera plus
fier par la question des congés bonifiés
parce que de plus en plus il y a des
médecins étrangers qui viennent qui ont
toutes les compétences et tous les
doigts mais quand on regarde bien les
sucres que ça va générer pour l'hôpital
public parce que les questions aussi de
cela ce n'est pas forcément vrai ici
dans l'Hexagone mais pour les congés
bonifiés c'est un doigt mais de plus en
plus il y a des demandes de prise en
charge pour aller dans des pays qui ne
sont pas ici de hexagone mais d'autres
pays pour les congés bonifiés ce qui
génère des secours considérable donc ça
seront des éléments à prendre en compte
de plus en plus on aura les prendre en
compte et là bon je ne sais pas s'il y a
bon dans le droit la possibilité de
permettre aux jeunes de nos territoires
de revenir pour limiter en tout cas les
dégâts parce que les coûts et les la
maîtrise des budgets ne sera pas
forcément
pertinentes il y aura un décalage si on
ne prend pas en compte tous ces éléments
là je vous remercie
terminer myliane Pomerol
merci de la présidente merci Monsieur le
Directeur désolé monsieur un sujet qui
passionne tout le monde et donc
effectivement on a tous envie de vous
poser des questions
moi je voulais revenir un petit peu sur
le problème qui a soulevé Bernard
jaumier et
à l'amidon qui a ensuite dans le même
sens sur la marchandisation la
financarisation de la santé qui est un
danger majeur j'ai alerté une fois on
faisait oliveran ensuite monsieur Braun
pour
cette dérive qui touche maintenant les
cendres soit primaires
London ça a été créé clinique et vous
savez quand on ouvrait le site Ramsay on
dit cher client n'est pas cher patient
on est cher client ce qui déjà en soi
un signe un signe très net les mots ont
un sens
mais maintenant ça touche les soins les
centres de soins primaires et on avait
posé la question sur le rachat en
particulier de centre tenu jusque là par
la la Croix Rouge et qui était rachetée
par Ramsay ce risque de dérive il va
entraîner effectivement des dépenses
supplémentaires sur pour la CPAM puisque
le but est de faire le plus d'acte
possible le plus le plus rapidement
possible alors moi je suis d'accord avec
un million pour dire pourquoi pas
effectivement on peut travailler sur sur
une BPL sur pas de publicité mais que
comptez-vous faire vous c'est que des
social CPM pour vraiment limiter
vérifier contrôler on parle beaucoup de
contrôle à fraude fiscal non pardon la
fraude sociale
on parle moins de la fraude fiscale on
en parle beaucoup moins de la grande
fraude fiscale c'est dommage mais là
qu'est-ce que vous avez comme moyen pour
vraiment limiter
cette financiarisation et je voudrais
revenir sur le sujet qui a soulevé à les
avaries sur les centres soins de non
programmés René Paul
excusez-moi c'est des formations ça veut
dire quelque chose
excusez-moi
j'étais alerté moi par le chef
urgentiste du CHU de Toulouse qui m'a
envoyé un courrier parce que les
urgentistes quittent l'hôpital alors
qu'on a déjà une pénurie d'urgentiste
qu'on a déjà une espèce de mercenariat
des urgentistes un peu partout les
urgentistes quittent l'hôpital pour
former des centres de soins non
programmé ou ne travaille que de 8h à
22h ils font pas de nuit ils font pas de
week-end ils gagnent mieux leur moins de
contraintes donc à l'hôpital mieux payé
qu'à l'hôpital et si on laisse faire on
va avoir une multiplication de ces
centres de soins perce des urgences pour
l'hôpital et par rapport au médecin
généraliste effectivement c'est pas du
tout le même suivi c'est pas du tout la
même qualité puisque ils font que de
l'acte non programmé voilà enfin un
dernier point juste sur la
reconnaissance des médecins traitants
vous avez beaucoup parlé de la
négociation au départ mais la
reconnaissance des médecins traitants
elle passe aussi par la
sur la qualité du travail qui font la
reconnaissance et si on veut attirer
avoir une certaine attractivité pour les
jeunes médecins et on a à l'occasion de
nos travaux à tous là sur les déserts
médicaux etc on a rencontré X fois les
jeunes les syndicats des jeunes internes
la rémunération était importante je j'ai
du mal aujourd'hui à comprendre qu'il y
a une telle différentiel entre une
consultation de médecins spécialiste
généraliste et d'un médecin spécialiste
dermato ou ophtalmo ou autres donc ça
pouvait autant sans se justifier
j'allais dire de mon temps où nous le
faisions que 7 ans et les spécialistes
en faisaient 10 aujourd'hui ils font
tous 10 ans et cette différence est
difficile à comprendre
merci alors on en a terminé avec les
questions moi j'ai reçu récemment j'ai
eu pas mal d'entretien
qui nécessite qui nécessitait je m'étais
engagée à vous poser des questions mais
le temps passe et je pense que je vous
propose de faire par écrit faire un
courrier ça concernait les des cabines
des cabines de télé un système de
téléconsultation mais qui est assez bien
organisé qui est dans l'air ça concerne
des opticiens à domicile ça concernait
la vaccination du HPV qui va être un
vrai sujet on a été aussi sollicité mais
il y a une réponse qui a été
partiellement donnée c'était sur le fait
que la CNAM reprenne les convocations
pour les centres de dépistage en matière
de cancer du sein cancer colorectal et
l'autre le troisième
enfin bref ce qui se fait dans les
centres ils avaient bon c'était la
reprise des rendez-vous par la CNAM mais
c'était surtout que pour eux puissent
continuer à avoir les données sauf si
l'objectif final et la mort de ces
centres de dépistage
il faut le dire d'emblée dans ce sens
dans ce cas là et puis et puis je pense
que par rapport à ce qui a été évoqué
sur parce que partout on entend ça cette
sorte de
ubérisation si je puis dire de la
médecine je pense que ça fera une belle
bon je ne serais plus là mais ça fera
une belle mission d'information de notre
commission sur ce sujet là tout ce qui
se passe c'est à la fois les centres
tous ces centres qui s'ouvrent tout ce
qui est mais aussi comment l'hôpital
public va-t-il pouvoir tenir si ce qui
faisait sa force et ce qui faisait sa
valeur en matière d'enseignement de
recherche et autres et maintenant dilué
dans d'autres dans d'autres
établissements et
je ne vois pas comment comment la
situation va pouvoir perdurer sinon ça
va l'hémorragie de professionnelle de
santé va continuer mais donc je vous
enverrai plutôt un courrier en sens
parce que sinon ça va être très en
retard et je vous laisse répondre à ces
questions
merci merci beaucoup je vais essayer de
répondre aux questions et marcheurs
milliers de rat sur les sujets fraudes
sur les sujets des
IPA des infirmiers en pratique avancées
en formation je vous confirme que on
nous souhaitons
et aider ces infirmières sur les deux
années qui
les voit rentrer en formation et qui
évidemment
ont un impact sur leur niveau de
rémunération et leur niveau de vie donc
il y a aujourd'hui beaucoup de
dispositifs qui sont pilotés par les
agences régionales de santé nous
travaillons étroitement avec elle avec
le ministère voir si nous pouvons de
notre côté mettre un mécanisme
conventionnel qui s'appliquerait partout
pour toutes les infirmières en pratique
avancées qui rentrent en formation
quitte à ce que la RS éventuellement
complète et c'est des sujets sur
lesquels nous discutons actuellement
aussi avec les infirmiers libéraux en
tout cas nous voyons bien que il y a
matière à mieux accompagner ces
professionnels sur la complexité de la
nomenclature elle est elle est oui elle
est réelle elle n'est pas que le fruit
de
[Musique]
de l'imagination de l'assurance maladie
elle est le fruit de la discussion avec
des partenaires conventionnels ces
sujets sont courts construits avec les
partenaires conventionnels en espace les
infirmiers
une des réponses que nous avons c'est il
faut en effet simplifier aussi mieux
accompagné marcheurs le disait depuis
maintenant presque deux ans ou un an et
demi nous accompagnons toutes les
nouvelles installations d'infirmières
libérales sur le territoire sur la prise
en main de la nomenclature première
visite dès l'installation nouvelle
visite à 4 mois nouvelle visite à 12
mois et ça fait partie des réponses
que nous voulons nous pas nous situer
uniquement dans le contrôle mais aussi
dans l'accompagnement et la prise en
main de cette nomenclature qui traduit
aussi quelque part la diversité de
l'intervention des infirmiers difficile
de considérer qu'on cote exactement la
même façon une perfusion un pansement un
pansement simple un pansement complexe
parce que c'est pas la même temps donc
de fait ça ça explique
une forme de complexité madame la sén
vous m'avez interrogé également sur les
sujets de coercition je n'y reviens pas
dans le détail sujet débattus à
l'Assemblée nationale en ce moment comme
vous le savez j'ai eu l'occasion il y a
je crois l'année dernière devant je
crois cette même commission de faire
part de mes réserves sur des mécanismes
de coercition au regard de une
démographie médicale qui est globalement
atone en tout cas qui va remonter
progressivement et que donc les tensions
se vérifient partout
au regard d'une répartition qui est tout
de même moins déséquilibrée que d'autres
professions de santé et au regard
également du signal que nous risquons
d'envoyer
en termes d'attractivité de la médecine
libérale dont nous avons encore une fois
à tout prix besoin mais je crois que les
différentes positions exprimées vont
également dans ce sens monsieur le
sénateur fichier je laisserai Mark
solaire évoqué les les plus que les
projets les outils que nous déployons
pour accélérer le repérage le ciblage et
et l'anticipation des fraudes je partage
à nouveau tout de même avec vous un
point qui est une réalité qui est que
notre système d'assurance maladie est
construit pour rembourser rapidement
rembourser rapidement les patients
rembourser rapidement les prochaines
annoncées
et c'est une nécessité
mettre en place des systèmes qui
s'intègrent dans ces dispositifs de
paiement rapide
des systèmes de contrôle a priori voilà
enrichi de détection ça nécessite des
refontes en profondeur ne nous outils
parce que tout le système de paiement il
est construit et ça n'est pas une
critique il est légitimement construit
sur l'objectif de payer bien mais
rapidement donc c'est ce que nous avons
engagé des innovations technologiques
qui sont en voilà qui qui sont en
possibles aujourd'hui nous permettent de
faire évoluer ces systèmes de
d'intégrer ce qu'on appelle des
contrôles embarqués et
programme que nous appelons de notre
côté qui s'appelle Meteor que nous
allons progressivement déployer 2023
2024-2-195 va intégrer ce type de
contrôle embarqué mais voilà je crois
qu'il faut qu'on repartage à nouveau
cette spécificité je te peut-être dire
un mot sur les outils et du coup
effectivement très rapidement mais
peut-être aussi d'abord se dire que nous
les risques que ça soit pour le paiement
à bon endroit que que vous évoquiez tout
à l'heure ou la fraude
c'est soit des des surfacturations
d'actes soit des facturations qui sont
des actes fictifs donc qui n'ont pas eu
lieu ou pour les assurer des droits et
des déclarations qui sont qui sont
falsifiées donc de fait il y a une
dimension extrêmement complexe à
identifier
ce qui n'a pas eu lieu ou ce qui est sur
facturé par rapport à la réalité des
actes qui ont été pratiquées puisque par
définition l'assurance maladie reçoit la
facture mais n'est pas dans la salle
dans laquelle les actes ont été réalisés
et dans le contexte que Thomas fatum
évoquait qui est un contexte de garantie
de paiement et de tiers payants qui
conduit de fait à liquider dans des
volumes que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
qui sont extrêmement significatifs à
virgule 5 milliards de factures par an
c'est je crois plus que pas mal de très
grosses entreprises en France et même à
l'international on a quand même des
structure une base de paiement qui est
extrêmement extrêmement significative et
le système était conçu comme ça alors du
coup évidemment là on est en train
d'intégrer donc d'une part pour faire de
la prévention de sujets qui sont ceux
sur lesquels on mise le plus puisque la
prévention de toute façon doit nous
permettre de limiter la fraude qu'on
évalue dans le cadre des évaluations que
l'assurance maladie réalise elle-même
c'est aussi un choix et une stratégie de
l'Assurance Maladie de donner la réalité
des choses telles qu'elles ont pu être
évoquées dans le débat public depuis un
certain temps c'est quand même nous qui
avons décidé de mettre en place ces
évaluations pour pour estimer la réalité
de ces risques donc il y a deux aspects
je vais pas revenir ce qu'on a déjà
évoqué à plusieurs reprises mais le
point important qui est de s'assurer
qu'un procèle de santé c'est coté
correctement quand il prend ses
fonctions ce n'est pas évident quand ils
pensaient fonctions il est formé à la
pratique médicale mais il a pas
nécessairement connaissance de toute la
nomenclature et
du coup ça il faut que ça intervienne
très rapidement après l'installation
pour s'assurer qu'ils ont dans une
relation de facturation correcte avec
l'assurance maladie et puis profiter du
coup des nouvelles technologies pour
intégrer dans nos systèmes d'information
mais c'est un peu plus long enfin 2024
2025 des compteurs qui nous permettent
de contrôler plus en amont et donc avant
paiement ce qui pourrait être atypique
ou un homme a dit ça c'est vraiment pour
la partie préventive et puis on a une
partie détective pour laquelle je vous
rassure du coup on
regarde ce qui se fait en termes de
nouvelles technologies donc qui nous
permettent à la fois d'avoir une analyse
comportementale des des professionnels
de santé notamment par différence par
rapport à leur père donc ce qui permet
de détecter des des atypies d'avoir des
ciblages efficaces on a aussi des outils
qui doivent nous permettre de détecter
les fausses ordonnances en circulation
et notamment avec l'information
puisse être utilisée par les par les
pharmacies puisque ça c'est un moyen de
lutter contre les trafics de médicaments
donc c'est des choses qu'on est en train
de mettre en place
des outils de modélisation des bandes
organisées donc notamment quand un
professionnel de santé prescripteur a
plus de relations avec d'autres
populations soit prescrites soit des
pharmacies du coup qui interrogent par
rapport à un flux normal on va voir un
médecin généraliste on a une
prescription va récupérer une boîte de
médicaments et voilà où la
surfacturation kilométrique et puis un
élément important du plomb du du qui a
été évoqué par le ministre quatre
routines notamment mais un qui doit
aussi permettre de remettre l'assuré et
ça c'était le point que j'évoquais au
début un peu au centre du jeu puisque le
tiers payant et la garantie de paiement
font que les assurés ont moins de
vigilance sur les dépenses qui sont
prises en charge en leur nom par
l'intermédiaire du tiers beyon et donc
qu'ils accèdent plus facilement à ces
données de remboursement et qu'ils aient
la possibilité de signaler à l'assurance
maladie des actes qui n'auraient pas eu
lieu ou en tout cas qui ont été facturés
pour des montants supérieurs à sereine
merci peut-être quelques éléments
complémentaires monsieur fichier ce
sénateur et d'autres d'ailleurs sur les
sur les consultations à 30 euros
je repartage surnomme avec vous deux
choses
il y a des règles qui sont fixées
d'ailleurs dans la convention médicale
qui sont des reprises dans le règlement
arbitrage qui sont pas fixés d'ailleurs
unilatéralement par l'assurance maladie
mais qui sont fixés conjoint noir avec
les médecins qui fixent le câble de
tarification un médecin peut pratiquer
un dépassement pour exigence
particulière du patient dans un certain
nombre de cas si autant une
revendication tarifaire est parfaitement
légitime voilà parfaitement légitime
autant en ciel se traduit par un
exercice systématique d'une cotation à
30 euros et de demander systématiquement
un dépassement exigences particulières
du patient alors on se situe en dehors
des règles de la Convention on expose le
patient arreste à charge qui n'est pas
justifié donc on expose les patients à
un reste à savoir ce qui n'est pas
justifié et donc l'assurance maladie
rappellera les règles du jeu au médecin
libéraux qui je l'espère j'en suis sûr
l'immense majorité d'entre eux quand
bien même il y a une discussion
tarifaire qui va reprendre qui doit
reprendre et qui est légitime mais qui
ne doit pas aboutir à faire reposer des
restes à charge injustifiées sur les
patients il n'est pas normal si un
médecin facture des frais annexes et il
fait supporter par les patients que leur
complémentaire ne prendra pas en charge
ce n'est pas prévu et donc je pense que
c'est important de se le redire madame
la sénatrice m'avait interrogé sur la
surmortalité ça n'est pas un sujet que
l'assurance maladie a dans son champ de
responsabilité c'est plutôt côté Insee
santé publique France partager avec vous
qui a des facteurs
divers en 2022 une grippe importante une
canicule importante qui explique
notamment des éléments de surmortalité
mais ça n'est pas dans notre champ on va
renforcer la compagnement des
recrutements d'assistants médicaux du
côté de l'assurance maladie on
simplifiant les démarches
administratives en accompagnant
également les médecins il y a des gros
pans d'employeur qui se créent également
pour simplifier les les tâches
administratives qui portent le contrat
de l'assistant médical et qui permet de
libérer la tâche administrative des
médecins sur la répartition des
dentistes c'est un sujet que nous
partageons avec les syndicats de
dentiste dans les négociations en cours
comment on peut mieux accompagner les
l'installation dans les zones sous
l'hôtel est-ce qu'il faut réguler
l'installation dans les zones
surdotées ça fait partie des thématiques
sur lesquelles les discussions ont été
engagées on soutiendra également le
recours à l'assistante dentaire qui a
été aussi
enrichi dans la dans la Loire East et
sur le l'attractivité de la médecine
générale les questions qui étaient
également posées par
Madame pomirol le simplement vous l'avez
vu le ministre a fait des annonces sur
la quatrième année de médecine générale
qui permet aussi de d'envoyer un signal
très fort d'attractivité de la médecine
générale d'une finalement d'une
structure de la formation qui devient
complètement
[Musique]
identique à sol de des autres
spécialités et avec des conditions de
rémunération attractive et donc une
première année quelque part dernière
année de formation de première année
d'exercice qui doit permettre de de
d'augmenter le nombre de médecins
généralistes qui vont s'installer ce que
nous voyons d'ailleurs dans nos chiffres
différentes questions sur la fraude je
n'y reviens pas le contrôle les arrêts
travail fait partie de nos priorités sur
les assureurs comme sur les
prescripteurs sur la contre les
facturation en EHPAD et également
d'ailleurs ancial et en achat des nous
avons en 2022 monnaie des contrôles qui
vérifient qu'il y a pas de double
facturation et avec des rendements
autour de 32 millions d'euros sur ces
opérations donc vérifiez que voilà ce
qui doit être pris en charge sur le
budget de l'EHPAD ou du CIAD n'a pas
vocation à être payé par la ville et
donc voilà ce que je peux vous indiquer
ce sénateur sol sur les médecins
stratégies je n'ai pas connaissance pour
tout vous dire de contraintes qui les
empêcheraient en tout cas libéral
voilà de faire du cumulants par retraite
on a aujourd'hui 13000 13000 médecins
libéraux qui font du cumulant par
retraite et sur un champ d'activité qui
leur appartient qui veulent travailler
un jour deux jours trois jours quatre
jours tout le temps ça leur appartient
donc on pourra tout à fait oui c'est
tout à fait possible donc on pourra
peut-être aller changer sur peut-être
des situations mais en tout et très
sincèrement on parlait des jeunes on
parle voilà le fait de de d'avoir des
conditions qui permettent à ces médecins
qui font du cumules en portrait voire
même à des médecins retraité de revenir
prendre de l'activité par exemple de
régulation c'est des choses que nous
voulons tout à fait soutenir ce sénateur
mignon mais d'autres ont évoqué à
nouveau la financearisation
je crois que comme vous m'y invitez tout
ce qui pourra
tout ce qui pourra conduire
traiter la santé comme un sujet de
consommation
doit être d'une certaine manière
combattue le terme est un peu vigoureux
et donc voilà tout ce qui pourra
permettre de réguler d'encadrer de
construire un recours aux soins qui ne
s'apparente pas à la consommation d'un
bien comme un autre j'y serai pour ma
part extrêmement favorable et madame la
Présidente évidemment sans que vous ayez
besoin de près ou loin de la quelconque
votre favorable de ma part si le Sénat
s'empare de ces sujets et je crois que
ce sera utile on se redisant également
je crois que c'est important que voilà
notre la particularité de du système
français et d'avoir des acteurs salariés
libéraux des acteurs publics privés des
acteurs privés lucratifs et non
lucratifs et donc je pense qu'il faut
trouver des voies de régulation
nouvelles en essayant de conserver cette
pluralité
d'acteurs pour notre part aussi on se
parlait de publicité on se parlait de
consommation nous allons nous
travaillons
avec aussi les acteurs sur une campagne
de communication sur le bon usage du
système de santé et nous le ferons nous
le ferons à la rentrée considérant aussi
que c'est notre responsabilité on parle
beaucoup des rendez-vous non non non on
aurait il faut aller au rendez-vous que
vous avez pris avec votre médecin et il
faut le prévenir si vous ne pouvez pas y
aller il y a des choses très simples et
je crois que c'est de notre
responsabilité à l'assurance maladie que
d'accompagner les patients de rappeler
les bons réflexes d'une d'un recours au
système de soins on va dire pertinent
madame la sénatrice jasmin sur vos
témoigner du fait que la CGSS et
notamment la CSO Guadeloupe est très
attentive au sujet de des transports
sanitaires des familles des évéquations
on est avec la RS avec l'hôpital je pour
m'y être rendu l'année dernière je sais
que c'est des sujets sur lequel on
essaye d'être de d'être en appui des
familles mais tout à fait preneur de
prolonger la discussion pour essayer de
voir s'il y a des voix encore
d'amélioration
madame la sénatrice
premier rôle le alors ça me permet de
dire une chose importante sur les
négociations avec les médecins
nous sommes favorables à engager des
évolutions qui permettent de
rééquilibrer les niveaux de rémunération
entre les généralistes et les autres
spécialistes sans vouloir revenir sur
les négociations qui n'ont pas abouties
mais les enveloppes financières qui
étaient prévus dans la négociation
précédente qui a échoué était très
favorable aux médecins généralistes on
était absolument pas sur un 55 ans
historique qui est 50% de l'enveloppe
pour les scénaristes 50% pour les
spécialistes on était sur une
répartition très favorable généraliste
je ne reviens pas sur le fait que ça n'a
pas fonctionné on va pas recommencer la
même chose mais clairement voilà un
généraliste aujourd'hui un revenu avant
impôts d'à peu près 90 000 euros un
spécialiste aujourd'hui en moyenne c'est
140 000 il faut se poser la question
d'entamer à équilibrage en se disant
aussi que il y a des spécialités
cliniques qui sont à des niveaux de
revenus inférieurs aux généralistes les
pédiatres les psychiatres sur lequel là
aussi on souhaite porter une attention
renforcée c'était aussi d'ailleurs
l'objet des négociations de soutenir ces
spécialités cliniques et donc c'est
vraiment notre intention et puis
peut-être vous rassurer sur le fait que
notre objectif n'est absolument pas de
remettre en cause le rôle des crcdc des
centres régionaux dépistage autour des
cancers on a des discussions très
approfondie avec avec eux y compris très
récemment il y a une quinzaine de jours
pour trouver le bon mode de relation les
ministres nous ont confié la
responsabilité de reprendre la gestion
des invitations suite à un rapport de
Ligue 1 qui témoignait
un système qui pouvait mieux fonctionner
mais nous voulons absolument travailler
en bonne intelligence avec eux y compris
dans le partage des informations et je
crois pouvoir vous dire que nous sommes
en train de trouver les voies et moyens
de d'articuler nos interventions mais je
crois que c'est important aussi qu'on
puisse voilà simplifier le système
d'invitation multiplier les opérations
d'allé vert les les généraliser c'est ce
que le rapport de Liga se pointait c'est
la faiblesse du dispositif actuel dans
ce domaine et donc nous allons mettre la
force de frappe de l'assurance maladie
sur le territoire au service de ces
opérations d'Albert mais en bonne
intelligence avec le Centre régionaux
des paysages on a besoin de ces centres
là il est hors de question de faire sans
eux je voulais vous rassurer sur ce
point voilà madame la Présidente
monsieur fantôme donc à chaque fois vous
venez il y a toujours beaucoup beaucoup
de questions il y a tellement de sujets
qui concernent c'est normal donc
pour concilier les agendas ont proposé
de commencer peut-être les auditions à
l'heure des matinales
6h45 ça me va à disposition
merci beaucoup merci